And then shut the [__] up. It's just a matter of
where the LINE IS RIGHT
>> OH, INJECTED DIRECTLY INTO MY VEINS. I don't give a
[__] if you don't think that it's a serious example.
In good faith, I I'm playing with you. It's banter. It's All
of the Josiah haters in my life, every single one of you is totally
blown out right now. If you're just going to condescend me, no,
thank you. I might lose it. I might totally [__]
lose it.
I heard Josiah talking right now. >> Josiah is going to
try to save this guy. I don't think he can be saved, man. I feel
you're much more aggressive with me than I am with you. That's
the big difference of a of opinion that we have. And no, I don't
think we can reconcile that, but I'm good with you having a different
belief on this. Like I again, I apologize if I Dude, sometimes
the banter may be Josiah, you understand that's Josiah being
like, I'm [__] done with you, mother I'll explain
after. I don't want you to get the sense that
I accept your apology. I I took it at face value just based on,
you know, many comments that you said. And I also wasn't looking
at your face when you're talking about I'm I'm listening to your
audio. It seemed like it was, you know, um it just it seemed
like it was genuinely condescending. And so, if Oh, IT'S CALLED
OUT OF THE VOTING. HUTCH CALLED OUT OF HIS CONDESCENDING PROMOTING.
LET'S GO. [screaming] LET'S GO. I MEAN I'VE BEEN KNOWN TO CONDESCEND
FROM TIME TO TIME. YES.
I know, I've I've been known to condescend from time to time.
Yes. But I think I don't know. To To my opinion, it kind of goes
both ways. Like I But I just I choose not to take that
For me, that's not off limits. And you know, where I guess this
is us just like establishing boundaries, right? But Well, well,
no, I mean, it it could be. I think part of the problem is I
Maybe it's because I don't think I condescend you. I think that,
you know, um you are certainly much I feel you're much more aggressive
with me than See, Hutch See, this is the thing. If you only If
you're not looking at Hutch's face while you talk to him, he
is communicating to his audience that you condescend him all
the time. He just communicated that. But I also feel that way
about a lot of people and I I usually like to keep my powder
dry and it could be just because I like to go harder on the right
than the left. And maybe that just needs to be part of it. And
you know, I just need to be willing to respond in kind. And you,
if I think you're condescending me, then I just fire back on
those terms. So, it's just I We talked about asymmetry earlier.
I don't want there to be any asymmetry in our relationship. You
condescend me, I have the right to condescend you. And if you
don't want that, then don't condescend me. Like I felt like the
dynamic that I had like that I have with like not just the old
cast, the new cast, too. It's like you know, we do you know,
kind of full send. And and that is that is part of the the content
the part of the appeal. And
You did full send until you basically leaned on Pisco the way
you did. You did full send, but that was the thing you opted
into. And then you leaned into the narrative that Pisco's way
too mean to you. And what did you think was going to >> Um
I would never tell you guys not to like full
Every Every time I hear this guy say something different or change
it it's like No, no, go hard on me and and we can just hash it
out that way and and you know, No, you opted out of that. You
know exactly what you did, you whiny
This is actually disgusting. You know exactly what you did. Like
it's fine if people like if people are saying like oh these bald
or like 40 40-year-old or like that stuff the superficial stuff
that I could give a [__] less. Like that like that
doesn't bother me. But if I look at the chat and it says um this
guy like it's with the with the particular crowd that I'm thinking
of, they relentlessly lie. Like relentlessly lie. Really probably
I don't know. If I ask your chat right now, like how many people
in your chat think that I was paid by PB to do Israeli propaganda?
That stuff I find that stuff I find like pretty unsettling. It's
It is an unsettling experience on the internet to look at a chat
and see like dozens of people saying that this guy was paid to
do Israeli propaganda. But like you acknowledge your chat goes
way beyond like what you see in my chat, right? Like the difference
again it's like the difference between like oh Pisco's arguing
in bad faith. Which is like you know, that's like you know, kind
of a nasty accusation. But like compare that to, you know, oh
well, you know, I got paid to do genocide apologia. Like that's
These are very different scales. >> Truly I truly didn't
think that you wanted me to do anything else, but I would love
to do a workshop with you about how you think I should approach
going forward. Maybe No, but I was No, but I was hearing you
say that nobody brought it up to you in the past, but that's
not true. No, people have brought it up to you in the past. People
on the podcast have brought it up. Again, if I'm if I'm bringing
it up in the way that I've done in the past, and it wasn't even
just me, but like if I'm bringing it up in that way, like bro,
your chat is wild. Some of the stuff they're saying about me
is wild.
What what do you think I'm saying by that? You think I'm just
like marveling at it like a like a waterfall or
Admit what you did. Yeah, I was there. I don't think you've ever
imposed that on us. I I and I can't speak for anybody else. I
don't you've never you've never said or suggested to me that
I can't go hard in the paint on you, but I know it bothers you
cuz you've said as much when you feel that you're being misrepresented
or straw manned or taken in bad faith that or some
He feels bad when he is in bad when he is operating in bad faith
and somebody is pressing him. And then when he says when that
person says, I don't believe you're being bad faith, so can you
answer this question? He goes, oh, why are you pressing me right
now? That is not it's it's not bad faith in the way you don't
believe it. It is not a good faith engagement. >> Somebody
has a reductive, you know, view of your beliefs. And I I feel
the same way. And and so like I said, it just for me, it's about
symmetry. Um if if you don't want that done to you, don't do
it to me. But if you're prepared to have it done to you, then
then go right ahead. I just I like having that sort of, you know,
even keel balance. And um but no, I I listen, I accept the apology.
It was done and over with as soon as you clarified, so we're
good. Um and I think the conversation has been much more productive
since then. >> DUDE, DUDE, DUDE, PESCO STRAIGHT UP LURKING
IN THE CHAT.
Who is rude, chat? One if Hutch, two if
Bro, what the
dive deep because of time constraints. Now I Now we've missed
what got
Josiah to the point that he was like, you're being condescending
to me. Which really I think we might have to go back entirely
there. And certainly in 2025 and 2026, Democrats have been over-performing
and Republicans have been losing elections very predictably.
And I also agree with you that all else being equal, he is facing
a shellacking in November. Now, I again, I guess I'm too much
of a cynic to to be as confident as you are because, you know,
we're still waiting to hear about
>> Dude, I have to go back. I will have to go back. I think
the disconnect is some I think sometimes maybe you you don't
your analysis does not offer or does not evaluate the areas where
Trump is strong and powerful and dangerous. Right. Sometimes
sometimes I get the impression that when you say he's weak, it
comes off like maybe you think he's impotent. And and I and I
think there's a way for both of these things to be true that
he's that he is as weak as you say, but also incredibly powerful
and incredibly dangerous in other ways that have people terrified.
We're only one year in. I think there's a I think I think there's
a fundamental difference in terms of in terms of how we just
You should never ever telegraph your enemy's weakness anyway.
There's a reason the US never ever ever ever talks about how
up the the Russian military is, the Chinese military. They they
never do that, right? They never they never give you like a real
a real idea of how weak the enemy is because otherwise you become
complacent, right? You should never be talking about how Trump
is, how the Republicans are. The only thing that leads to is
complacency. It's just self It's like mental mastur- that only
leads to weakness on your part, okay?
Don't do it. think about these things. Um I'm much more I would
say
I don't think about like the fact that he's president for the
next 3 years. I can't really do anything about that. That was
baked in November of 2024. As soon as it became clear that he
was going to be the president,
that was it. I mean, I accepted I accepted it that night. I mean,
I got to a place of like accept- I wasn't happy, but I got to
a place of acceptance about it that night. And so, I think about
things in terms of not about like I just me in my life just like
personally in my life, I don't I used to spend a lot of time
thinking about the worst case scenario that could play out in
my I know what happened now. Wait, now I'm thinking back.
Did Josiah go back? Did somebody tell Josiah, "Hey, take a look
at Hutch condescending to you with his face?" Did somebody send
that to J'zaih and go, "Hey, I hope you know, while it may have
sounded like Hutch was being respectful, if you look at his face
here, he's being a total ass to you." Cuz I wasn't I was asleep.
By the way, I can't be blamed for this. I was asleep.
I was sleeping. I was sleeping. Okay? But, that's actually what
I suspect
would have happened here.
Worse than with words? Oh, even less. Again, saying totally Look,
even Look at even less again.
Being the biggest
How is that not actually worse? Being explicitly duplicitous.
Trying to be nice, but making faces to your chat so they can
tell that you don't you don't really respect the other person.
And then you say these people are your
That's so much worse, man. And he is a complete prick about it
all the time. All the time. And you're this like booming content
creator. And so, I know you know what it's like to be in a really
good situation, but you're just consumed with like, "Oh my god,
What did J'zaih first rejoin with?" >> heard that a lot
like a thousand times. And bro, I'm legitimately I'm legitimately
way more excited for this than this State of the Union. I don't
know if that explains my process, but I'm just thinking about
it. >> It does. It does. Like I said, I just I I think
that's probably the disconnect for me. Again, I can't speak for
anybody else. Like, Trump is weak, yes, but he's also powerful,
yes. Like, he's he's not he's not he's not just weak, and he's
not just powerful. He's >> I mean, he's weaker than Biden
in some ways. He's weaker than Bi- Biden was The whole thing
was on rhetoric.
And rhetorically,
you you basically have to you have nothing to explain the gap
in the total failure of the policies of the Trump administration.
The first Trump administration.
And them being reelected. You've nothing else. If it's not rhetoric,
if they're not way better rhetoric than you, you can't explain
it. It it makes no sense. That's the only thing that fills that
gap in. So, for Hutch to say, "No, actually, the Democrats are
really good at rhetoric. They're like as good as the Republicans
at rhetoric." It's You're obviously wrong. You're just obviously
totally wrong.
I don't even know why you say it. It sounds so stupid. It is
your inability to admit any strength in your opponent because
you hate them. Right? You can't admit what they're good at. That's
a great indication you don't have a good read on a situation
when you can't even say what your opponent is good at. Why are
they If they're bad If they're worse than you in every way, then
they're not somebody you should be talking about. If you're talking
about somebody who is worse than you in every imaginable way,
then you are a loser. People are like, "Oh, they don't hear Hutch
out." No, they do. Hutch is incapable of expressing the idea
correctly. That's where your frustration comes from. It's not
because Pisco actually like tries to walk down the idea. It's
because you actually hate that Hutch can't represent your idea
correctly. I just hear you say I'm I'm like way far behind, but
that I am too online, that I'm one of the two online craps. Can
you unpack that for me? I'm just going to listen. No, but hang
on. Hang on. I'm going off of what Pisco said, okay? Pisco said
>> you maybe saying that we should ignore the courts.
Oh, I've talked in the past about This is a debate I've I've
had for years. I'm not entirely >> Uh-oh. Hutch came in
a little Sorry, Josiah came in a little heated. >> the
president of the United States, no matter who it is, is obligated
to always obey the Supreme Court because president and this is
it's a notion called non-acquiescence, and it really has its
genesis, for all intents and purposes, during the Civil War because
President Lincoln disregarded a court order by Chief Justice
Taney about um habeas corpus, and his logic was at the time like,
"If I obey this order, it's basically going to jeopardize the
war effort. Do I have to forego my duty to, you know, take care
of that all the other laws be faithful um for the sake of this
one?" And so, it's it's something that's been been debated by
judicial scholars for centuries. Um it's something that yeah,
I I absolutely think about because the the the What the entailment
there is that the Supreme Court is the boss of Congress and the
president. And it's actually intended to be the weakest of the
three branches, weaker than the president, certainly weaker than
Congress. Can you give me a Can you give me a real-world application?
Give me a hypothetical where you think it might be appropriate.
Like a realistic kind of real-world
Um In the modern context.
Oh, that I probably couldn't give you one offhand. I don't think
I've ever called for non-acquiescence in like the modern time.
I can't think of it as like a single example, but it's a philosophical
notion that there are Supreme Court orders that in theory, I
think the president should just ignore. Like again, you know,
like Civil War and things of that nature. Well, I mean
Tell me how it came up in the context of you talking about the
recent >> Oh, oh, there's one There is one There is one
modern example. Well, no, cuz Peace Bone I talk about this all
the time because we talk about balance of power, separation of
powers, which branch is supposed So, I will say this does get
you out of the world where
J.D. Vance does the Andrew Jackson quote, right? The Chief Justice
has handed down his ruling. Now, let him enforce it. While you're
president, you are the enforcement arm. Like you you literally
I hope you know you can't touch me. You obviously can't touch
me. >> dominant over the others. This is These are like
common conversations that we've had. Um just like structural
uh conversations about the system of government. But, there's
one example actually I can think of where I flirted with non-acquiescence
and that was during the Biden administration um about the debt
ceiling, okay? So, I I can't remember all the details that times.
It was like 2022, 2023 when we needed to lift the debt ceiling
and there was a potential government shutdown because uh the
Republicans weren't going to um you know, necessarily give the
votes and there was a lot of debate about whether or not Biden
should mint a trillion-dollar coin or something like that in
order to knock off enough debt so that we we have some room before
we hit the debt ceiling. Um and there was a debate about whether
or not the Supreme Court would force President Biden to um uh
default on our debt. If if you can't if you can't uh come to
an agreement to satisfy the statutory obligations to raise the
raise or suspend the debt ceiling. If the Supreme Court said
um uh yeah, we got to default on our debt because the president
is still spending money that he's not congressionally authorized
to use, um maybe the president should just ignore them and continue
to do it. You're going to have to try to order me to default
on the national debt and trigger a global economic catastrophe.
Besides And and Lawrence Tribe, Harvard Professor Lawrence Tribe,
one of the most reputable in the business, also made the case
that the president might just want to ignore what the Supreme
Court says. Listen, you're my boy and I love you. Just want you
to know that.
Appreciate that. I Dude. Dude, that's crazy. That That was a
crazy cuz it's funny cuz I do think I That was probably one of
my main criticisms of Pisco's. I think the you're you're my boy
thing, I do think it was used in a bit of a condescending
I do think it was I think it was and I do think Hutch is like
at a lower level and so it's like I didn't like it, but I was
like at least when he decides that like so much a higher level
than Hutch in terms of political analysis. I can't tell you guys,
okay? People don't know Josiah behind the scenes at all. Josiah,
I I think I'll I'll start with an insult, okay? So it doesn't
sound like I'm glazing him too much. I think his channel's content
is total slop, okay? But it's slop that I think it's probably
turned him into you know, based on a conversation I had with
somebody who was a little familiar,
It was uh
He was making He's He might already be like a multi-millionaire
based off of how his channel does, okay? It is the Midas slop
algorithm, but he put He was working like 80 90-hour weeks between
his channel and his occupation to make that channel take off.
This guy works so hard, okay?
He puts so much time into politics. You can't fathom it, okay?
You can't fathom how much time he puts into politics, okay? So
for Hutch to just go to listen to all of that, that's all well-reasoned,
thought-out thought-out positions that he's probably argued with
his friends who also spend a bunch of time wonking out, right?
And then Hutch just goes, "You know you're my boy, right?"
I I might lose it. I might totally lose it, okay? He is totally
He is extremely
okay? And for somebody to without any of that to just go,
"You know you're my boy. You just You know you're my guy, right?
You know you You know you got me, right?"
honey, sweetie, baby,
sweetheart, honey, baby, you're you're you're fine, but like
you don't know what you're talking about. Huh. Just want you
to know that.
Appreciate that, buddy. That's really online, buddy. That's really
online. Uh you know, that's really super online. >> what
you
So, this is why this is again why dude, the tweet the tea the
the tweet was
Actually, frankly speaking, Pisco has always been far too nice
to Hutch.
pretty much everybody's always far too nice to Hutch. The fact
that he feels any amount that he can condescend to anybody shows
that people are too kind.
That's how it is. I I I cracked right away, okay?
it's just obvious that people are too nice. And by too nice,
I don't mean like they're too nice as in
I I literally just mean that when Hutch is wrong, he's incapable
of identifying that he's wrong, or when he's incapable of participating
in the conversation, nobody points it out to him. That that's
what's happening.
Pisco, oh, you're my boy, or whatever,
But that's like there are
That would be the kind thing to do, in my opinion. You by not
pointing out that he doesn't understand, by not And the only
person who would ever like walk this down in a Socratic way instead
of directly, so that can be a little condescending, a little
annoying for some people,
was Pisco.
Pretty much everybody else would kind of like let this hang and
and let him like punch himself out, and then they just reiterate
their point. And
but it's it can't be allowed to happen. So, it's very funny that
this has gone this way. You asked me for an example, what what
the hell does that mean? You're talking about ignoring the Supreme
Court, Josiah. This is a really online not serious thing.
So, Hutch just didn't listen to anything
I will say when he did this to Aaron, I thought he was being
said
but it seems to not be he seems to be doing it to people who
are very well researched, men who are ahead of him in that same
industry. That's got That That takes some balls to do that same
like I'm going to totally ignore everything you just said and
restate my opinion
without integrating without understanding. Dude, I've had conversations
about how this guy works.
I'm so correct. Right? When I talk about he can't synthesize.
He's incapable of synthesis on the fly.
Which is which is probably like an
I don't know if you call it a cognitive disability. A lot of
people aren't capable of it, okay? To like walk through, to have
a constructed mental model in your head that is that is something
you can
A lot of people's mental models, the way they think about the
world are like
they're like buildings. And when you want to renovate a building,
you have to tear something out of it. You have to like build
like scaffolding. You have to tear something out and you have
to like if you want to renovate, right? And there are other people
who have like mental models that are built out of like
Right? That you can really like iterate slowly. You can pull
things down. You can put things up very quickly. There's no like
downtime. There's nothing like this, right?
And the way Hutch thinks about something, his mental model is
like totally inelastic. It's fragile
and he's incapable of updating it in real time. So, he's not
capable of like basically you you have an opinion. You listen
to someone else's opinion. You see where that opinion conflicts
with yours. And if you agree with them, you can snap out your
thing and figure out
you can snap their thing in. Like they're connects. Do you anybody
remember connects? You're like trying to put take their opinion
and integrate it with yours, and that requires like fairly complicated
thinking because you have to think of like not just the first
order effect, but like second order
Like how does that affect other
Right? Oh, I'm switching on this. What principle does that sort
of violate of mine or what principle does it uphold? How does
it How does it update everything else I think? So, do you have
something like a that is a an unironic like neural network that
can update all the other nodes in your thought process, everything
else in the model, right? And those people are truly intelligent.
The people who could take in new information and they immediately
like you see it you see the light turn on in their head and they
go, "Oh, this changes everything,
And I
Not a lot of Not everybody's like that. And I always appreciate
when somebody's like that. When I see that I've like given them
a new piece and they can snap everything together immediately.
And Hutch isn't like that. And it's very frustrating to watch
because somebody will have a point that should really spark something
in his mind, right?
And the mind doesn't It doesn't spark.
And so, what happens is is somebody's making a good point that
sort of either refutes or is like parallel to his point in valid
invalidity,
and he can't recognize it because that would require updating
his mental model, which he can't do. And so, the only choice
then is to reassert what his current model is and be obstinate
about it. It's very frustrating to watch for me that I see these
people who are very capable of this, who I watch them or I talk
to them because they're very capable of this in real time.
And and then I see Hutch who is like this he just put it he just
put it dead.
That is what is frustrating for me. He just He just takes the
the
and he shoots it dead immediately.
And it's super frustrating, okay? If he believed what he did
and he was just capable of actually responding back to what Josiah
said, it wouldn't actually be that big a deal to me that he just
disagrees. I'm totally fine with disagree who can argue back,
right?
Honestly, if he just had the sensibility to like pivot to something
else, that might even be enough to like keep the conversation
moving. But he like shoots it dead and just restates the same
thing he just stated.
And this is the same This is the same phenomenon we watched last
night where Hutch said, "Why are you freaking out? We're crushing
it in the polling right
And Rashad said, "What I I know we're crushing in the polling,
but here's why I think it's happening and here's why I think
we can't rely on it." And Hutch said, "Yeah, but we're crushing
it in the polling right now."
It's the same thing just happened here where Hutch said, "That's
I I kind of thought it might be a really online opinion." And
Josiah goes, "Well, here's all of the ways that we think that
the Supreme Court's been, you know, the Supreme Court basically
here's why
protecting liberty might require ignoring the Supreme Court.
It could, possibly. It actually could."
And Hutch goes, "Man, that's just really online." He doesn't
engage with it. He doesn't He doesn't acknowledge.
It's It is a It is a form of I didn't but I didn't eat breakfast.
Yes, it is a form of that. And it's incredibly frustrating to
And I think this is what's actually upsetting so many people
and it's what upset me so much about people going after Pisco
is Pisco is not trying
Pisco There's two tactics you could adopt. You either point this
out to Hutch that you're incapable or you're being super bad
faith or you can try to Socratically walk around it and show
them how their opinion could change or should change. Those are
the options you have and Pisco chose the one that's least destructive
to the relationship,
which is not calling him a lying not pointing out that he is
foundationally and at a genetic level
He picked, "I'm going to try to Socratically walk around this
and let Hutch realize that he's maybe wrong and can somehow catch
up to us, right?
That's why it's so frustrating to me to see Pisco get attacked.
Okay? Like if you start advocating for a Why would it stop there?
At that point, if you just ignore the court that blatantly in
that kind of way, why would you stop there? And at that point
at that point you are >> but just I Are you telling me
there are no circumstances under no circumstances can the President
of the United States or Congress disregard the Supreme Court?
You can't think of any? >> No, yes, but >> Then shut
the [__] up. It's just a matter of where THE LINE
IS.
>> INJECTED DIRECTLY INTO MY VEINS. YES.
INJECTED DIRECTLY INTO MY VEINS.
Everybody who doubted Josiah, all of the Josiah haters in my
life,
every single one of you is totally blown out right now.
YEAH. YES. Thank you. Sorry, I just had to play it again. >> kind
of way, why would you stop there? And at that point at that point
you are speaking Josiah, but just I Are you telling me there
are no circumstances under no circumstances can the President
of the United States or Congress
No, yes, but Then shut the [__] up. It's just a matter
of where the line is. So You invoked the Hey, [__]
your Bro, you invoked
It's It's so perfect, right?
It is just again like a a perfect microcosm of it. You invoked
the civil war. Josiah, You invoked the civil war. [__]
it. You're right. So there's a line, Hutch. Yes. >> So
So again, [__] your holier-than-thou
Josiah, you asked me for a specific
Policy parade?
>> Explain to me where you disagree with my rant about
how this guy has no synthetic thought process whatsoever.
Explain to me where you disagree
or [__] off.
Okay? I I personally am in the Hutch is cognitively impaired
camp compared to his compatriots, okay?
I think he's he's mentally incapable. I will continue to think
he's mentally incapable until proven otherwise. >> We need
an example of where I You asked me for You asked me for a specific
example outside of a civil war. And then you said that there
was one that I was flirting with. And by the way, and by the
way, it's not just me at highly educated individuals scholars.
All right, Lawrence Tribe, famous and not serious person. >> It's
not serious. You're not thinking about it. Like you invoked the
last time that happened. >> my god. Oh my god. Bro, I let
you talk. I answered your question and you're spending all the
time condescending me. I answered you in good faith. I don't
give If you don't think I don't give a If you don't think that
it's a serious example in good faith, I I'm playing with you.
It's banter. It's banter. Chill. It's It's banter. It's banter.
It's banter. No, it wasn't. Dude,
banter
could be funny, but you would have to go, that's totally online,
bro. But here's what I would say. He didn't do that, right?
Banter would be, okay, but I am actually going to answer you
seriously. It wouldn't just be to go, oh, it's banter, and then
to continue on with that point. Was this today? Yes. It was today.
It's not serious, but it is banter. But you're saying I know
you're being I know you well enough to know I know you well enough
to know when you're being serious, and you just admitted >> I'm
being half serious. Let me Let me Let me respond to it then.
No, wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
If you're just going to condescend You're being belligerent.
If you're just going to condescend me, no, thank you. What? Are
you pulling out of the conversation then? I won't condescend
you. I will be so nice and
Then proceed. Okay. You brought up the last time that this happened,
non-acquiescence, in the context of a civil war. Obviously, that
is a totally different calculation. If we are at the point where
we're in a civil war, then dude, so many bets like all bets are
off. Like, you know, you try to preserve the system as much as
you can. I told you guys I told you guys yesterday, just keep
asking Hutch when you shoot Hitler. That's all you got to do.
When do you shoot Hitler? That's all this is. It's the when do
you shoot Hitler hypothetical.
That's exactly what it is. And then you you know you At the same
time you're you're in a war with people that want to take it
over and maybe do like a fascist takeover and do like a coup
or whatever and like basically destroy the system. At that point
you have to make all kinds of compromises. I mean, I'm like of
course like there were illiberal things that happened when we
were fighting the Civil War, but we're not there right now. We
are We are like 20 steps removed from that. And I just want to
ask you if you think that it's a realistic If it's 20 steps removed
from that and you're not even close, then all of your hand-wringing
over Hasan [__] not wanting to endorse Gavin Newsom
is [__] Right? He And again, he literally cannot
tell
He can't understand where the things he says integrate with his
other opinions, like how they affect them. So, when he says we're
20 steps away or when we're super far away, that's what he's
intimating. It's we're super far away from considering this,
right? We're super far away from considering non-acquiescence.
That means if you're not super far away that your arguments about
how fascism's knocking on the door
aren't correct.
Either fascism's not knocking on the door or you're or you're
super far away from non-acquiescence. It's one or the other.
Okay? That's There's no other way to look at it. like solution
to just start ignoring the Supreme Court. And I'm just asking
you like do you not think at that point that the right-wing in
this country are going to take up arms and just it's just on
like Donkey Kong at that point, right?
That That is a possibility. That's what I Don't you want to avoid
that? Don't you want to avoid that, bro?
Your opponents are attempting to exercise non-acquiescence at
every step of the way. The Vice President has talked about non-acquiescence
as a strategy for years.
You are there. You are there, you bald
idiot. Do you Trump Trump obviously is like tapping like dipping
his toe into non-acquiescence when he takes forever to respond
to any Supreme Court order and he argues with his cabinet and
there's leaks about him arguing with his cabinet that they don't
have to
The literal President of the United States is trying to not acquiesce
currently. You remember how this topic just came up?
You asked me about about me saying that you were too online.
Right. So, I asked you a question, very specific question. You
said, "Well, it's based off something I heard from Pesco about
the Supreme Court." And I said, "Well, there is this notion called
non-acquiescence, and it's happened in the past. It's just very,
very rare, and it's something that's being discussed and has
been discussed for centuries by judicial scholars." And I gave
you a specific example. Then you wanted to focus on non-acquiescence,
and you said, "Well, why would you be talking about that with
Pesco?" Well, again, Pesco and I have conversations like a lot
broad abstract conversations about separation of powers and checks
and balances all the time. >> Right. And then when you
asked me for what non-Civil War example could I possibly conceive
of where non-acquiescence might be permissible, I said, I remembered
the one about the debt ceiling. Because if we defaulted on our
debt, it would trigger a domestic and global economic catastrophe
that would probably make the Great Depression look like a walk
in the park, which is why at the time there were judicial scholars
like Lawrence Tribe and others suggesting that maybe if the the
president forces the issue to the Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court says, "You need to default on the debt because you didn't
statutorily meet the terms of raising or suspending the debt
ceiling," that the president, for the sake of the domestic and
global economy, should just give the court the finger and keep
uh spending money to pay off the debt. That I said that was an
example where, of course, I considered
And you responded with the most unhinged, condescending rant,
"How dare you even think in such a scenario about violating or
disregarding the Supreme Court? And if we did it, wouldn't the
right, you know, raise up in rebellion?" I'm not suggesting that
that is something that any president, Democrat or Republican,
invoke on the regular, but I can imagine some extraordinary crisis,
like either a civil war or a domestic or global economic catastrophe,
where the court could probably be ignored for the greater good.
Now, having reiterated that all again, do you really think that
responding the way you did was appropriate? Listen, the context
Listen, what you're saying right now is reasonable to me, okay?
If you're having you know, Josiah Josiah let me talk, okay? The
context of all of this was we I was in a debate last night with
Rashad and Pisco started to to to do the thing that he does with
me where he like he like tries he like tries to trap me in hypocrisy
or something like that. He brought you
Bro, Pisco doesn't try to trap trap you in hypocrisy.
This is Dude, dude, it's actually there's no way he's going to
throw Pisco under the bus here. So you bear This guy is so embarrassing.
Not a friend. Not a friend.
Not a friend. Actually so embarrassing. >> And he said,
"Josiah's been talking about like ignoring the court." That's
what he said to me. So that was my impression, right? That's
what I'm thinking, right? And so you come in and and and then
you you talk about the Civil War and then you mention the other
thing. I'm still in my head thinking like, you know, this is
not the only application that that it's come up. I mean, are
there other times where you suggested that possibly Biden should
have ignored the Supreme Court or we should or the next Democratic
president should possibly ignore the Supreme Court. Was that
the Was that the only time it came up?
I can't think of any other example where I told Pisco like a
like a specific example where the court should be >> Okay,
I had the wrong Listen, I had the wrong impression then, >> But
here's here's the frustration. I I gave you all that information
before you responded the way you did. And this is actually part
of the problem, right? Which is going back to my initial question
about where you said where I'm too online.
And I've said this to you before and Wait a minute. I've said
this to you before and I said this to you I've said this to you
in multiple conversations before, including the one earlier today,
where you and I can just exchange straw men about one another
if you want. No, I'm No, I'm glad you clarified. Listen, I'm
glad [laughter] you clarified. I appreciate that. So then Hang
on. I'm giving you like insight into why I was thinking this
The reason I said anything online, I was responding to Dude,
how many times does Hutch have to say that if liberalism fails,
he knows civil war would be what's left? Okay, this is the argument.
The the thing here is like
It's like bro, they're like they're literally like hanging Democrats
on the on the steps of Congress, okay? And you're like, dude,
I don't know if we could consider non-acquiescence as a strategy.
It might be civil war at that point. Like this is it's not quite
there, but it's like way closer to that than Hutch is letting
on or Hutch is off on his other rhetoric. I'm not sure which
one, okay? >> He's He's got said, you are start quote and
I think I quote here. He said Josiah is starting to talk about
like possibly ignoring the Supreme Court. So that's what I'm
working off of, bro. That's what That's what's in my head. Um
I So maybe maybe Pisco only said that. I would guess it's cuz
he got cut off or something. I feel like Pisco's usually pretty
precise when he speaks. In fact, it's sort of the thing he's
known for, being incredibly precise, like overly precise when
he speaks. Blurting, okay, okay, blurting. context, I hear that
and I'm like that's way too online if we're just casually talking
about ignoring the Supreme Court. If you're talking about a a
potential hypothetical where it's, you know, like the global
meltdown of the entire like interconnected economy, if it's like
avoiding [clears throat] that, then it's the same like trolley
problem, harm reduction principle. I would totally be willing
to enter But again, my impression of where you were at and you
being too online. Wait, can you acknowledge that though? If I'm
If I'm >> no, no, no, I can't. No, no, no, respectfully,
I can't. Not I understand you having that impression going in,
but then when you asked the question the first time and I answered
it, then whatever This is This is the thing
that that's the thing, right? Hutch said you're too online and
Josiah goes, I'm not too online and here's a whole thing I've
talked about with people and why I think it's like a principled
and like reasonable discussion to have and Hutch goes, yeah,
that's way too online, bro.
Just didn't respond. Yeah, it she just didn't respond. >> misapprehension
you were under or um implication you got from Pisco should have
went out the window. >> No, come on, bro. No, yes, yes,
because Peace Corps didn't give you specific examples. Now, if
you'll allow me to to talk about the context that Peace Corps
and I have talked about this in. So, one of the issues that I
wrestle with all the time in my version of the Supreme Court
or my assessment of the Supreme Court is the fact that we don't
have three co-equal branches. We have three coordinate branches.
And the founders were very, very clear that the Supreme Court
was intended to be the weakest of the branches, weaker than the
president, and Congress was supposed to be stronger than both.
It's supposed to be Congress
then the president, then the Supreme Court. And one of the things
that I wrestle with all the time is in practice, it's actually
the Supreme Court on top because the Supreme Court can effectively
issue commands to the other two Well, but that's not true.
And not acquiescence is just like facts. And obviously the founders,
that's exactly why it's the weakest, right? Is it literally can't
enforce its will at all. And this has been pointed out like,
okay, I don't have to Well, sorry, I don't have to educate Hakeem
on this or educate anyone on this. We all know We all know exactly
why. I'm just going to let him keep talking. I have to use the
bathroom really quickly. I've drank like two liters of water
already. I'll be right back. branches.
And the expectation since Marbury versus Madison, and particularly
since the Civil War, has been if the Supreme Court issues an
order, the other two branches are obligated to obey. So, the
Supreme Court can strike down federal statute
and can also strike down executive
Well, what options do the other two branches have? Well, Congress
really can't do anything, right? If if the If Congress passes
a law and it's signed into law by the president, so you have
two branches versus one. The Supreme Court reviews that law passed
by Congress, signed by the president, and says, "Oh, it's unconstitutional.
We're striking it down." The only way to get around that at that
point other than getting the court to change its mind or packing
the court or something is to do a constitutional amendment. And
we've had 27 constitutional amendments in 250 years out of literally
more than 10,000 attempts. We have the hardest constitution to
amend in the world. And the The by himself is effectively totally
powerless against the Supreme Court. The Supreme Court can tell
the president no, and then under our current system, the president
is obligated to obey. So, as I've talked with Pisco multiple
times, how is that if anything other than a total inversion of
what the founders intended? If I can tell you no, and you're
obligated to obey, then we're not equals. I'm your boss. So,
we've had that conversation, but I have never
So, uh hold on. Hold on. So, implied by that, right? If that's
the way it works, oh hold on. I did I wasn't watching the face.
I wasn't watching the face. Hold on. Implied by that is that
if the founders set out the these rules that appear to make the
presidency the weakest, right? But they say the presidency should
be the strongest,
then there might be something in there about them intending the
idea that like here's the way it works normally, but ultimately
the president does get to make that decision, right? That would
be another case of a norm holding up your system that if people
respect it,
then the system works, but suddenly if you have a president who's
a total narcissist, right?
Unfortunate pause. Wait, where's the pause? What do you mean?
to obey. So, as I've talked with Pisco multiple times, how is
that if anything other than a total inversion of what the founders
intended? If I can tell you no, and you're obligated to obey,
then we're not equals. I'm your boss. So, we've had that conversation,
but I have never that I can think of ever advocated other than
the the debt ceiling situation for a president to just simply
disregard the Supreme Court. But philosophically, and in terms
of checks and balances and separation of powers, yes, I think
it's a really good question because the Supreme Court is ultimately
in our current system the most powerful branch. >> But
you know I'm a but so hang on. I just want to hold on. I'm pulling
up the transcript from the podcast last night. I just want to
I just want to get exactly what was said, okay? Cuz if memory
serves correctly, [__] [snorts] where is it? I do
a control F search for Desai, and it's not popping up popping
up. I don't know the exact timestamp.
Yeah, I remember what he said. I understand. So, I think I think
Pesco was a bit overstating Okay. my [clears throat] position.
All right. >> But, we have talked about the notion of non-acquiescence.
And as far as the
Uh we need a little lighter dude. Thank you for the gifted sub.
I appreciate it, man. Thank you. Thank you. >> But, the
only one I can think of ever publicly flirting with is the death
ceiling example. But, again, Hush, I love you. You're a friend
and that's part of the reason why I was like, I'm not playing.
You really me off. And the reason you really me off is I understand
if you had a certain conception of me based on what Pesco said.
But, as soon as you ask the question and I'm like, well, I can't
I can't think of a single example. And then and then I'm like,
okay, well, here's this one specific modern example. And for
you to react the way that you did is incredibly disrespectful
and condescending, especially for a guy who doesn't like you
say all the time. You've said it in conversations with me about
how
Pesco misrepresenting someone to win an argument. He would never.
I actually don't think Pesco misrepresented it. Because I've
heard Destroya talk about non-acquiescence as a strategy before.
I've heard him mention it. He has literally talked to me about
it. He I've I feel like I've had the conversation on stream about
how powerful the Supreme Court is before.
I feel like I've I've had that same conversation. I don't think
it's Pesco's the only one he's talked about it with. I know he's
like flirted with that idea. He's talked about how like But,
because guess what? These are basically parallel concepts, packing
the court and non-acquiescence. Those are are nearly parallel
concepts, right? As Destroya just discussed, there's another
way to get around this. Packing the court is one of the ways.
He's talked about packing the court positively and I think that's
what we
Was literally packing the court. Now, I'd say I'm not sure how
those two match up against each other. I'm I'm sure I could think
of some other stuff here.
I know he's flirted with these ideas cuz I've seen him talking
about these ideas. So, if the if the verb he used, Pesco, was
flirting with these ideas, he's absolutely done that. It's not
even overstating it, okay? You feel that you know you're being
straw manned or misrepresented. You ask people to, you know give
the the steel man of your impression. I feel you do that to me.
And so that's why I came in here actually just ask the question
like But you're steamrolling right now. Let me just say real
quick, I had I had a totally different impression and it was
not my intention to straw man you. And it does look like I was
mischaracterizing
your perspective. And I wasn't doing that intentionally. I was
working off of in my head again, I'm being told
I don't think the founders meant weaker in the way Josiah and
Pisco are using
The impression is that you're starting to talk about non-acquiescence
in a more general sense. Okay, so that's where my head is at
and when you gave me your one specific answer, that doesn't like
nullify what I heard. Like you that wasn't you saying this is
the only time Uh I super I'll be honest, I kind of don't care
about the state of the Union as much. Maybe we can go through
it a little bit fast, okay? I'll see if we can go through it
fast. >> Whatever, I entertain that. I'm still in my head
going off of what Pisco told me, which is that he's starting
to talk about doing that. Okay? So if if like for for misrepresenting
anything you said, I apologize. I really do. I I appreciate Next
time you could just ask. Next time you could just ask besides
the debt ceiling crisis Josiah, since I was given to believe
that this is something you really want to do. It was a throw
It was a throwaway line. That's all it was. It wasn't even you
know
It wasn't a throwaway line after he came
on the stream.
Pause. It wasn't a throwaway line, right? He He did the throwaway
line. Josiah came in and said, "Hey, I don't think that's true."
And then said, "Here's like the example I have." And you're like,
"That's really online, bro." I have You doubled down on it. If
it was a throwaway line, WHY DID YOU DOUBLE DOWN on it after
he gave you his
Right? He's just lying. He is a weaselly little liar, dude. He's
a weaselly little liar, dude.
Right? It can't be a throwaway line if you threw it away and
then Josiah gave you his entire opinion and a whole bunch and
an example. Like he gave you his whole opinion and an example
and you go, "That's really online, bro."
Well, I'm like strong agreements with with like Steven right
now. And I said the same thing about him, but it's not it is
kind of like half banter, okay?
I was not working off of it sounds like the reality of the situation.
If you're saying that the whole non-acquiescence thing came up
in the context of this particular thing and the greater harm
in this case could be like a global catastrophic meltdown, then
sure I would entertain that and I would say that you're not too
online, okay? I had I did not have again But he he did all of
that. He did all of that and then you said you're way too
You're just lying. You're just gaslighting him because you are
a liar. You are incapable of like synthetic thought. You you
have no flexibility in your thought process and now you're gaslighting
him to try to make him get back on your side. You're just lying.
Admit that you're just being a prick.
Literally, I was being an [__] I'm sorry. I shouldn't
have done that. I was being an [__] This you're trying
to gaslight him so he gets less angry at you, but you did something
wrong. Just apologize for doing the wrong thing.
I'm not going to say that >> I did not have the correct
impression of your attitude with respect to non-acquiescence.
And I agree with you on like 99% of your prescriptions when it
comes to the courts. Right. And so again, the the only other
Dude, you you all see it, right? How he refuses to admit that
he was just wrong and I apologize. I I said something bad about
you and I didn't I didn't understand and I was wrong. I'm I'm
sorry. I was wrong. I was wrong to do that. It I wasn't just
wrong in my opinion. I was wrong to do that to you. I wronged
you.
By condescending to you like that when I didn't understand. The
time this has come up is just broad structural philosophical
notions like is are the other two branches obligated to obey
the Supreme Court and if so, doesn't that necessitate that the
Supreme Court be the most powerful branch if they can tell the
other two branches what to do, but neither of the other two branches
can tell it what to do. Seems to be a vertical relationship and
not a horizontal relationship. I agree with the binding code
of ethics. I agree with the binding code of ethics. I agree with
term limits. I
But do you agree with the idea that if they meant for the presidency
to be the strongest branch, right? Sorry, no no, they meant for
Congress. That Sorry, if they meant for Congress to be the strongest
branch, then obviously the and and that's that's guaranteed by
the impeachment process, right? That Congress is the strongest
branch. That technically they are the ultimate check on the president.
They can they can remove the president, right? Although then
I don't know if the enforcement arm kicks in there. How do you
remove the president if he wishes not to be removed? I'm not
totally sure. I think I think it's still Congress, though, okay?
In terms of authority.
Then the president must have some way that he could check SCOTUS
in like a major way, which is I've decided not to enforce this,
right?
Ultimately, the issue with the US Constitution, the separation
of powers, is that there Basically, they decided with a couple
of these things, it's like, we're going to assume good faith
on the part of the president. That's pretty much what keeps the
system running. It's like the president's not going to be a totally
disingenuous scumbag. And then you got a president that's a totally
disingenuous scumbag. I would be open to packing the courts.
Like, you know this about me. I I I I know, but I know and that's
not I'm but I'm not talking about that. I'm I'm trying to give
you the context of when it non-acquiescence has come up in conversations
with Peace Go. How is packing the courts um not essentially parallel
to
I do I do believe that packing the courts is essentially like
a parallel thing in terms of liberalism.
You are violating the norms you are you are violating the norms
of your country to get your way. The process is set in place,
right? You're violating them. You're violating them in spirit
if not in in legality. But non-acquiescence, I don't think there's
anything that says that I don't think there's any
like charge you could levy for non-acquiescence. If you have
congressional support, if you're not going to get impeached,
and you decide not to acquiesce, I think that's just fine. I
think under the Constitution, they basically have given you that
power because they think the the case where you'd have to use
that power is so is so crazy that you just need to do it, right?
But you you probably I I feel like you almost certainly have
it. The The check on that is supposed to be the Congress willing
being willing to impeach the president.
The only specific example are the Civil War example with President
Lincoln and Chief Justice Taney. And the debt ceiling crisis
under Biden. Okay. Now, that aside, as far as the two online
part, because I remember you saying this, it's wasn't even just
about the Supreme Court, but again, about the strength of Trump.
So, that's actually it wasn't even about the court why I came
in here. I came to ask you why you think I'm too online when
it comes to Trump. And I'm curious if you could clarify a bit
more. I'm trying I'm trying to figure out where we're missing
each other. You touched on it a bit earlier, but I had to go
and record some video. So, now that I have time, can you talk
about it a bit more? Ooh.
And at this point, I am going to go and grab the timestamp and
go to the beginning for the their conversation early in the day,
okay? Can we please stop pretending like our political opponents
are like operating from good faith and they want the best and
it's really just a little disagreements. It's like, no, it's
not. Okay, I I can appreciate all that, but but you seem to have
the view that the next Democratic, you know, broad sweeping mandate
that's going to come in are going to win on a platform of, you
know, you balked a little bit on like concentration camps, but
just like, you know, brutal punishment of the MAGA movement.
I don't think that's true. I don't think that's what's going
to win elections. That hasn't been what has won us elections.
>> Well, if if you don't know where the electorate's going
to be at 4 years from now. Yeah, but like imagine if like conservatives
commit to Imagine if conservatives commit to a campaign strategy
of demagoguery. If you have no idea that's what's going to connect
with >> thought like you, none of this would be happening
for them right now. If they thought if they thought the way you
think about >> I'm a [__] liberal. None of
Yeah, no, what I'm saying is if they thought the way you did,
a lot of their victories they have right now wouldn't exist.
You can't look at the future and say, well, I don't know what's
going to happen, so I'm not going to be proactive. You be proactive
where you can and you let the let the chips fall where they may,
but you don't sit there and see the public Hold on. You don't
sit there and see conservatives do something that objectively
works. HOW ARE THEY DOING RIGHT NOW? How are they doing right
now? How are they doing right now? The advantage that we have
is our politics like you said. No, but how are they doing right
now? You're saying they're these masterminds that are like these
masterminds. You're skipping You're skipping to the L instead
of looking at the W that gets cut in half to get the L. You're
missing the part where they won and then did a bunch of evil
stuff. To do the evil [__] you got to win. Okay.
But I was listening I I was like 2 hours behind. I was listening
to um some of your um stream. But the only thing I would say
is I do think you and Rashad were slightly talking past one another
and that's just as much his fault as yours cuz he's imprecise
on certain things. No, it was not as much Rashad's fault as Hutch's.
It was not. Uh Rashad had things you could criticize. The rhetoric
wasn't always clean. But it wasn't He's not the one who couldn't
understand. I know. I know. I agree with you that in terms of
winning elections, particularly in the short term, um Democrats
shouldn't really [__] with the formula. It's working.
I agree with you. I think what Rashad is saying is
he wants to return to an era where there was uninterrupted control
of the federal government by one party. I and I think that's
what he's talking about. Now, you may still disagree with his
suggestions on the substance, but I think what he is saying is
okay, being anti-Trump and campaigning on affordability in the
age of Trump is a good way in the move-by-move, inch-by-inch
short term to win elections. Mhm. And it's clearly working to
your point. It's the common denominator with Sherrill and Spanberger
and Mondani, right? Yeah. But he's he he's he's trying to offer
what he believes is a more durable vision so that the next election
won't go to the Republicans. And he does have a point there if
not in terms of his proffered solution. He does have a point
where there has been particularly since Trump a back and forth.
I mean, this is the first uninterrupted Biden was the first uninterrupted
Democratic presidency in that he didn't get a second term
since Jimmy Carter, right? And and the first since in general
since President >> Wait. So I think I think what he's saying
is having like durable long-lasting control so that the changes
to the systems can be made to prevent or reduce the likelihood
of a future Trump and for Democrats to pass a a lot of progressive
policies or more or more beneficial policies even if you don't
like the the taste of progressivism. Let me uh >> make
sense? Yes.
I guess my frustration
sweet brother Josiah who is my boy and who I love very dearly.
My frustration is that
it's it does sound a bit
fan fan fanciful
idealistic I I do think Rashad was a bit reductive in this respect
and and I've said like Cenk Uygur's kind of like my archetypal
example of somebody who's like, "Oh, you know, just give me 90
days and I could just snap my fingers and I'll have everything
solved." Like I agree with you like that's >> Yeah. not
uh It's the same thing. It's the same thing. >> I certainly
I certainly agree with you that he was presenting it much more
straightforwardly than I think is reasonable. Um and and so I
agree with you there but um
Where was I going with that? Um you're talking about uh
Well, let me let me let me Let me let me let me let me let me
let me let me filibuster single payer health care and I'll get
back to you. >> Don't filibuster me. >> No, you you
I was trying to respond to you and I had a really good point
I was >> a you're Hassaning me right now. You're Hassaning
me right now in the conversation with Kyle. >> and that's
that's really why I'm here. You and Hasan and Hutch >> spoke
for a decent amount of >> You and you know, listen, you
and Hasan have so much you they both start with an H, okay? The
the similarities between you two are really galling. That's the
other reason I'm here to stage an intervention. You made No,
shut up. You made like 10 points. Let me Let me talk, okay? So,
like >> you weren't done with my points. >> not done.
No. So, >> Okay, I I apologize. Go ahead. >> Okay.
So, it's That's not the only thing that's frustrating, though.
Um Okay.
A big source of my frustration these days is something that I'm
seeing all over the place. It it It came up many, many times
on the podcast when you were um one of the
>> idea that the way that that that that liberals and and
leftists talk about
completely like the the the rhetoric and the framing just completely
acquiesces
to Trump's propaganda about himself. Like Trump's whole thing
is he's trying
But you Hold on. I Mhm.
Trump paints himself as like a a guy Like here's the thing.
It's It is different.
Trump consistently talks about himself as like the greatest president
who's getting all of these things done.
The rhetoric about him being strong is that you you're pointing
out that that isn't true and nobody can see that. Nobody who
votes for him can see that. It's not you saying that it is true
this most consequential president that he's getting a bunch of
[__] done. It's saying he's lying to people about
what he's getting done, and nobody can see through it, and that's
terrifying. The rhetoric is strong, which is actually the point
they were making on the podcast about rhetoric, how strong they
were rhetorically. And Hutch said, "No, no, no, no, no. I think
you're underestimating Democrats rhetorically."
Which was just insane. It was an insane thing to say.
Literally everybody's problem, including Hutch's with the last
election, was that Dems couldn't get their rhetoric out. They
weren't speaking enough. He's like, "Well, no, I think Dems are
super effective rhetorically." And Rashad's like, "Yeah, but
they didn't go on
And Hutch is like, "Well, I agree with that." It's so they didn't
use the primary platform used to spread their rhetoric. Wouldn't
that make them weak
By definition.
Project like manliness
and assertiveness
and strength and political dominance. Like that's his whole thing.
I won by every I won by the largest margins and then for I did
very well in Maine, you know, I almost won Maine and I frankly
think that in California, you know, like that that's his whole
thing is he just lies about how strong he is over and over and
over again. And it seems like I hear rhetoric from people like
you and people like Rashad and people like like everybody seems
to be doing this. Where they buy into that and they're like,
look at Trump, he gets everything he wants.
You know, he's just like really strong politician. Meanwhile,
the Democrats don't have any balls in their Yeah, you see, it's
all about the Democrat insult. He's willing to cause complacency.
He's willing to to He's willing to lie to people directly because
he just doesn't want to say that Trump's right on something or
or he doesn't want to, you know, have a positive thing said about
Trump when he interprets as a positive thing. It's not a positive
thing. It's literally it's terrifying to me that Trump is so
strong rhetorically that despite lying about everything, nobody
cares. They just look at the rhetoric. Factless and they have
no vision. Like none of that corresponds with reality, Josiah.
And it drives me insane that that people accept this framing.
Yeah, I understand, but I wasn't there yesterday. I think you're
being a bit reductive in my view cuz I we could just we could
just exchange straw men, right? So, I could say that
you you have your head up your ass because I'm from Wisconsin
powerful everything you never take that into consideration and
he won the presidential election twice and if you're concerned
about people being you know, subscribing to an inf-
So, this is what Josiah's talking about in the next conversation.
When Hutch talks about getting bullied, when he's like getting
mad that Pisco's being mean to him or something, when Hutch thinks
the other person is wrong, instead of being a man
and arguing and saying this is what part of your point is wrong.
Right? He just makes faces like a child. >> election twice.
And if you're concerned about people being, um, you know, subscribing
to an inflated sense of Trump's power that you make him sound
like he's the weakest [__] in the world when he is
not. So, the thing happening here is not Josiah describing Hutch's
position. Josiah is saying to Hutch, "Hey Hutch, I think you've
like totally straw manned me here and I don't want to do the
same thing. I could by saying something like this, but I don't
think that's what you believe." That's what Josiah is saying
right now. I'm pretty sure Hutch just heard that you are describing
me as that and he's like lost his mind. What? So, we could exchange
the Dr. version of each other. >> I never >> Wait.
Hang on a second. Wait a minute. I I I understand. I understand.
And I never said that Trump gets everything he wants and Democrats
never get everything they want. So, let's not do this cuz Yeah,
he Again, it is literally an example, Hutch. He is giving you
an example
of what a straw man could be. And you And he heard that. He's
like, "Speaking of straw man And no, he was literally telling
you this is a straw man. This is not what I think you think.
This is a straw man I could do, but I don't want to do. So, can
we just have a real conversation?"
Cuz we could do this all day. You think I err on the side of
Democrats are too weak and Trump is too strong. I think you err
on this idea that Trump is weak. Not just weaker, but weak when
he is the most powerful person in the world by far. Infinitely
more powerful >> That's a typical conversation. than any
in the world. No, it doesn't. No, it is. That's a conversation
about Josiah, you're No, you're being disingenuous. You're being
disingenuous. There's There's a whole other thing going on here.
Right? Which I They're not hitting on or Josiah's going to hit
it on the current purpose or on the current point with the current
power, right?
The current power is scary because of how he was able to obtain
the current power despite the fact that he tried to like coup
the government in 2020.
Okay? 2021 technically. But, that's what's make That's what makes
it scary is rhetorically he can make that go away. Rhetorically
he can somehow hypnotize people into ignoring that. Right? And
it's not really that he's the only one who could do it and I
think some people are going Some people are just sitting here
going, "I pray that Trump's the only person who could do that.
I pray that Trump's the only person who could do that." I promise
you, Trump is not the only person who could do that. And I This
is why last night I said, "Age 35 for Fuentes isn't that far
away." I know he can do it. I know he's better than Trump at
it. That's terrifying, okay? Not that I do think he'll be president,
but it's like I know he could be. And if he was going to advise
somebody, he could do that now. Tucker is better Tucker is not
better at the Trump thing, but he is better at some things than
Trump. He's smarter than Trump for sure. I don't think Tucker's
going to be the guy, but we'll see.
If Fuentes just advises somebody,
that's terrifying in and of itself, okay? Cuz he is better at
the Trump thing than Trump himself is.
He understands it better by far. That's why he's able to succeed
and become one of the biggest influencers in the world with totally
insane ideas that he's basically said on every platform
before and been banned and now after. Hasn't really changed hasn't
really moderated that much.
Right? So,
the idea that oh, Trump's gone and then we have we get rid of
this whole thing, that's wrong. You're wrong, okay?
That's the thing that makes this scary is that rhetorical power.
The The ability of these people to ignore the
as long as somebody is willing to espouse or defend certain values.
>> I'm not finished. I'm not finished this on, okay? So,
listen to me. We're still stuck with Trump for the next 3 years.
I agree that his polling is in the toilet. Um he's only passed
one major uh legislative uh bill and that was the one big beautiful
bill and he's already ruled out a reconciliation package in 2026.
Keep talking. Keep talking. Keep talking. I can hear you. I'm
just going to go in the other go in the other room to turn the
AC down, but I can hear you. Keep talking. That's fine. Yeah.
So, no, I totally agree with you there, but again, let's not
let's not exchange straw men here. I'm just trying to represent
where I think you and Rashad were were talking past each other.
There has to be a way that even if you disagree with Rashad's
approach or or Rashad's proffered strategies, Rashad is saying
that we need to try to build a durable
Josiah, give Hutch more respect than to call him a Assad. Bro,
this chat totally ignores this dude making faces at every one
of his friends, totally of being a massive [__] to
them, right? Uh hey, Josiah, could you give Hutch more respect?
No, I won't give him more respect until he starts until he stops
doing these
faces, acting like I'm the one who's
How about you get some brain get some brain matter in your skull,
okay?
Connect some neurons and see what he does to me when I make my
argument that I don't do to him when he makes his argument, okay?
Stop being fooled by these faces he makes. He does them because
they work, because you guys are fooled by them. How about everybody
in Hutch's audience
stop drinking to get through the stream,
Only sober viewers on Hutch's stream from now on. His viewership
drops to zero, okay? There there's that's the only explanation
for anyone following along with this and not understanding what's
platform which could result in long-lasting congressional majorities
or long-lasting Democratic control of the White House. And I've
been sounding the alarm on this, too, because the institutional
disadvantages we face are making that much more difficult. And
so, again, I I I totally agree with you that in the short term,
in the age of Trump, and I think Rashad even conceded that, too,
that in terms of winning elections, campaigning on being anti-Trump
and and pro-affordability is the way to do it. Adopt the the
Spanberger and Sherrill and and Zorn and Udall approach. Um but
we do need to be thinking about what we can do in the background
or in parallel uh to try to put Democrats in a position where
we have longer control over these institutions to make the necessary
changes. And I know he said single-payer health care and stuff
like that. I'm I would I mean, obviously, I would prefer um uh
you know, more universal health care in this country, but I'm
not even suggesting that. I'm thinking more about anti-corruption
measures and changes to the Supreme Court.
Oh, bad prediction for Pisco. Josiah's going to get sucked into
a 2-hour combo. I feel it. >> care about. >> That did
not happen. >> agree with you on those things, Josiah,
and I it does drive me insane when you say that we were talking
past each other. No, we weren't. I want the same things. I want
to address these structural hurdles. You've heard me say a thousand
times that I would want a policy like court reforms. You've heard
me a thousand times. I I I would prefer major structural changes
to the to the Senate. >> You know, I would be even open
to, you know, scrapping the Senate entirely and just switching
to like a parliament. >> Doing doing like a parliament,
right? Like um you so you know I'm already thinking about these
things. Things. It's not that we were talking past each other.
He was saying he didn't he just didn't want to own it. He was
he was advocating for a policy, Josiah, of throwing out the Constitution.
Don't you understand? Like he was literally saying that, but
he just didn't want to own that. And so when I would press him
on that, he was saying stuff like if a judge rules badly in in
in a case
>> not owning it. He was literally explaining to you we
have like an illiberal enemy
that is willing to throw out the
Are we willing to to take things to another level to defend that?
That was what he was saying, which you don't even have to agree
with that argument. Everybody you is a totally valid argument
to say engaging in those tactics means that the republic is already
fallen and I will not do that. If we cannot win without doing
that, then America is doomed. That is a totally valid position.
But Hutch doesn't say that. Hutch just goes, "Huh, are you really
saying that you don't want to be a liberal, bro? Are you really
saying are you really you're really to be illiberal? Huh, you're
[clears throat] you're like going to throw out the Constitution
and stuff?" He doesn't say like he doesn't show any understanding.
He just condescends.
That's it. >> like arrest like use the institution to target
Fox News. Now, I'm not even completely opposed to that, right?
Like if they violate some FCC regulation or if they break the
law or you know, if The Biden administration tabled like that
that I'm going to FCC >> I wasn't finished saying. Or if
they if they slander a company like Dominion, you have like civil
options there. But he was saying like he was presupposing a crime
and he was just saying like you need to lock up like Fox News
and throw them in jail. And then I asked him, well, what do you
do if, you know, like Newsom DOJ
arrest the murder I don't even think By the way, Rashad's not
getting creative. Just remove their broadcasting licenses. Just
be like, actually, you've lost your ability to do this. You don't
get to do this anymore. Good luck, you're an internet-only company
now. Good luck on YouTube.
Go to YouTube.
Trump was willing to take away Jimmy Trump was willing to threat
FEC licensing, sorry, not FEC, but FCC licensing. He's willing
to threaten that through Brendan Carr over Jimmy Kimmel.
Of course you could threaten that over the the whole Dominion
voting scandal with Fox given what evidence came out. >> and
take them to trial and then like doesn't even like propose a
crime or like they concoct a crime. He said something like conspiracy
against rights or like, you know, conspiring with Donald Trump
to be a propaganda arm of like he wasn't naming any crimes. He
was
Joining in a criminal conspiracy for a RICO case is a part of
the crime. That's the whole point. Did you act in furtherance
of the conspiracy?
I don't know. Also, I don't know why Rashad didn't say that.
I don't know why Pasco didn't say that. That makes me think that
somehow the RICO case couldn't be applied, but I don't understand
how you couldn't apply the RICO case to specific people when
they have absolutely
acted in furtherance of the the election fraud conspiracy.
It seems like they would obviously be like parties to that litigation
if if you could make that case. Just saying we need to use the
state to like punish Fox News. He wasn't talking about legal
mechanism. He wasn't talking about a mechanism within the liberal
framework. And then when I asked him, what do you do if you take
that to the judge and the judge says, what the [__]
there's no case here. >> he said remove the judge. >> Yeah,
just remove the judge. Like we are beyond liberalism at that
point, Josiah. Do you don't you understand that? So how is he
So how is he How is he talking past me in that moment? What What
do you think I'm not understanding, Josiah? So, I didn't mention
that moment because I'm not defending that. I'm talking about
the first part of the conversation where you were talking about
what Democrats have been doing since 2024 to win elections in
2025 and in 2026. And he was saying, "Okay, yeah, sure, but also
we need to be doing things or signaling in ways to build more
durable congressional majorities, more long-lasting congressional
majorities and control of the presidency." That's where I'm saying
I think you two were talking past each other because you kept
saying, "Okay, well, we just need to do what we're doing now
to win elections." And he was talking about something else. >> Okay,
yes, this helps in the short term and Trump, but what about post-Trump?
What are What can we do to return to an >> I mean, objectively,
he was. Stop saying no. That's objectively what he was
Stop just saying no. Stop shaking your
That's literally what he was saying.
of a decade-long control of the House of Representatives or you
know, two, three, four back-to-back-to-back terms
in the White House. That's where That's what I'm interested in.
I agree with you that yeah, it towards the end there when he's
talking about throwing out judges, like even to impeach a judge,
you would need two-thirds of the Senate to do such a thing, right?
>> wasn't even talking about impeaching. He was just like
remove them as president. Just Just remove them. That's what
he was saying. >> There's no Yeah, there's no like mechanism
to do that unless he's talking about like arresting the judges.
Yeah. I'm not That's That's not what I'm talking about. And maybe
that's what you want to talk about, but I want to talk about
the first part of things where I do think you were legitimately
talking past each other because it was totally non-responsive.
So, I would like to hear from you, Hutch. What do you think Democrats
should do? Not just in the short term winning elections, but
in terms of changes to the party or policy or party agenda or
party policies. Yeah, to to have a more durable long-lasting
political control over at least the two political branches. >> I'm
perfectly happy to get into that. And in fact, in fact, we've
gotten into that a thousand times. Like there's There's like
I think a number of problems that are going on with the Democratic
Party right now. The The number one problem that I think is happening
right now is something that I know we've talked about a thousand
times. You can You can boil it down and really oversimplify it
and be like Kamala Harris should go on Rogan. But really, when
we talk about that, we're talking about a much, much bigger problem.
I don't disagree with Pisco necessarily about the myopic nature
of media engagement that the Democratic Party is engaged in in
the modern era. I just think they are so behind the curve and
I will say that >> Agreed. So again, this is another example
of like Hutch can't combine
two positions he has
and see where they contradict each other. He is incapable of
this, right? So this is another example where he's like, well
yes, Democrats are like very, very weak at at using media correctly.
They do not use media correctly. It's like a major problem for
them. And then when they say, then when somebody says, well,
Republicans are actually very effective rhetorically. They get
their ideas out and they can even lie like almost with impunity.
And then Hutch goes, yeah, but have you seen like I wouldn't
say Republicans are better at rhetoric or messaging. They're
like, have you seen Democrats and how they do it? It's like he
reflexively defends Democrats in that exact one case
without thinking about it. And he said something that totally
contradicts the previously said statement, which is right in
this case, right? I guess it wasn't previously said, it's said
now, but that Democrats are really bad at using certain media
channels.
That is a part of it.
And he just can't tell how these two opinions like fail to coexist.
They can't coexist in a coherent world view. >> I think
that's getting better. You know, like the the the the fact that
Newsom invited you to go have a conversation with him. That is
an indication to me that the Democratic Party has taken that
space more seriously. And so I'm I'm encouraged, but I need to
see a lot more, you know, like I I I I was telling my chat and
I'm I'm not even kidding when I say this. Ken Martin should pick
up the phone and call Gavin Newsom. He should call Momdani and
summon them to have a meeting and tell them to bring all of their
team and then literally 3X, 4X all of their salaries, give them
a fat budget and tell them to just go nuts. Like we need to think
like really big, really creatively. We need to lean into these
spaces way, way, way more. But then below that, I mean, the reason
I would put that as like the highest priority is because I do
think that the social media space is becoming slash maybe has
become  more important than legacy media at this
point. I think more more people more people that are like the
the ones that are voting the the primary electorate even the
boomers are spending so much time looking at their phones these
days. And so um if you can't fix that problem if you can't compete
with the Republicans in that arena then the
We need to get Gavin on live and learn after Hassan comes on.
Let's go. >> that the reforms don't even [__]
matter cuz we're just going to keep losing um winnable elections.
And so that I mean the second thing is like the structural things
that you're talking about. There are serious structural imbalances
right now that are significantly
disadvantaging uh the Democratic Party in ways that I consider
to be undemocratic. So we talked about the problems with the
Senate talked about the problems with like the Supreme Court.
I mean and there are there are we talked about the problem with
like the filibuster. Like these are things that need to be addressed.
And like I I I I I hope that we elect enough Democrats in the
Senate to get rid of the filibuster and actually start like start
the process of you know getting past these hurdles you know.
And and we can go we can keep going down another reasons right
Uh the steel man is that the actual messages Dems promote are
fine but they don't amplify that speech enough and are and are
used to outdated models or outdated modes of media, TV ads, radio
spots, literature versus Republicans who sound like morons but
they get more clicks and bring their messages to the masses.
Uh there is a also there's a whole problem of Dems are still
fairly elitist. They want to take the policies that they believe
in not come up with a coherent narrative. I we talked about this
last night as well straight right. I I don't think you were here
but um in my opinion now uh you you do not you don't try to make
a story that takes all of your policy positions into account
and promotes all of them. You come up with the narrative, the
story you want to tell, why the country's failing, where it needs
to go and then you pick the policies that go along with that
and you are willing to say okay we have to backtrack on certain
policies or not not include them cuz they don't fit with the
narrative. The the policies or you just say we're going to implement
them. Just stop talking about it. We'll implement it after we
win.
Story first,
facts later. This is what Fuentes does. Fuentes Fuentes has his
whole story about how Israel dominates, right? He's got enough
facts sprinkled into it that it sounds believable. It's difficult
to You would have to fact-check a lot of it to see how it's like
misleading people in certain ways. But he came up with the story
first, right? His whole story about the Clean Break memo, Israel
trying to destabilize the entire Middle East, right? All this
stuff.
It's arguable. It's arguable. He doesn't look like a when he
talks about it,
Can he prove out every element of it? No. But that doesn't matter
because the narrative becomes self-reinforcing. Once you start
seeing things that fit with that narrative in the world, even
if you can't prove them, that solidifies the narrative. That's
why Fuentes, I believe, has seen such a massive rise with the
Israel-Gaza war, right? Because his narrative, the narrative
he was talking about before this, has been cemented. So, there's
two elements to this. First, come up with some narrative that
people are willing to be receptive to in some part now, figure
out how to make it adaptable, and and figure out something that's
going to happen in the future. That that narrative becomes stronger
the longer you go, okay? I do believe there's something to hey,
the wealth discrepancy in this country is starting to hit a breaking
point. Jobs are going to keep disappearing. They're going to
keep getting offshored. You're going to keep losing your economic
opportunities. The economic power of the individual citizens
in this country will drain away and continue to drain away until
we fix it. I believe that's an inevitable outcome. If you build
that up as some enemy is making that happen, and you show that
Republicans are in bed with the exact people who are benefiting
from it,
that's gas, okay? That's That's
That's napalm, all right? Now, unfortunately, that's going to
sound kind of communist. That's going to sound kind of crazy.
I'm not even going to say that that couldn't go to an extremist
place. But I think that's the narrative. I think that's what
you roll with. I think napalm. The reason Bernie Sanders failed
is because he failed he was doing this out of the time that the
American like
economy was at the height of where it had ever been. They were
coming out of the recession, things were going gangbusters, right?
I think that's why Bernie kind of had a stumble.
Trust me. Trust me. That stumble is going to I would I would
try to avoid the communist imagery for this whole story, but
this story works and it will
I think this is where it go I think this is how you go through
with it, okay? But I don't know. I'm I'm still thinking about
it. We're trying to make it work better, okay? Trying to figure
out where you can make tweaks. >> why I get frustrated
when you say that we were talking past each other is that's not
true. I understood what he was saying. He was saying at that
point in the conversation Josiah that the Democratic Party should
run on a platform of demagoguery.
He was saying that this is like and his whole thing vilifying
the Republicans, yeah. I mean
Did he just say that to Josiah? Did he think about who he's talking
to? Josiah, Rashad's saying that the Democrats should like talk
[__] about Trump and Republicans.
Like brother, you're talking to like the Joseph Goebbels of that
exact process, okay? Hutch, do you know who you're talking to
right now?
And the way that Joseph Goebbels was able to paint the Jews to
the average German, that's Josiah's job. That's what Josiah's
passion is for painting Republicans as like evil and destructive
to your country, okay? You're literally talking to the guy. Can
you imagine that this guy wants to be like he wants to engage
in demagoguery against the opponent? It's like Yes, I think I
think Josiah can imagine that to be honest. I do think so. >> accountability
And his whole thing was this was in service of this like larger
plan that you're speaking to cuz we need to be able to secure,
you know, 10-year majorities and 20-year majorities, okay? That
was his whole thing.
Josiah, my pushback to this is that nobody knows how to nobody
can tell you a strategy right now. And I do think I
Rashad goes too far. I don't think I don't think there's any
advantage to impugning. I do think there's some nationalist element
you have to roll into this where you don't impugn the general
character of the average American. Even though they're questionable
character of the average I have I have questions about the character
of the average American, okay? I think we can all agree on that
one. You're you're in a weird place right now. There's probably
some questions, all right? You don't do that as a politician.
Maybe you do that as a media figure. You never do that as a politician,
okay? Always looks bad, always works against you, always in the
back of their head people always will think, "Oh, that could
be me." Even if they hate the other side, they'll still think,
"Oh, but you're like saying Americans are like this." You you
don't do it to that big a group, >> This far in advance
of like what is going to land with the electorate. There is no
such thing as >> a a 10-year plan on messaging. That you
like there's it's a false bill of goods. This is a fantastical
idea. It doesn't make any sense. The You see, this is where this
is again where Hutch is too um rigid. Too rigid in his thinking,
right? And Josiah thinks that Hold on, what did Pisco say? Josiah
thinks that's based, the demagoguery thing?
Yeah, I mean he just said that. >> This far in advance
of like what is going to land with the electorate. There is no
such thing as like a 10-year plan on messaging. That you like
there's it's a false bill of What does Hutch think Project 2025
was?
What does Hutch think that is? When the Heritage Foundation makes
its plans, what does Hutch think they're doing? Does he think
they're they're like planning and then if they don't win in those
four years they scrap the whole thing, they throw it out and
they
does he not get it?
I disagree with what you're proffering. I don't think demagoguery
will work cuz I know you challenged him on that that you didn't
think it would work or you at least questioned that it would
work. He thinks it works for he knows it works for Trump at least
in the short term political gain. He thinks that there's something
to be exploited by Democrats here. Clearly Gavin Newsom to some
extent also agrees with that, right? And clearly there's support
for that in the base. The base wants a more ruthless populist
messaging not just in terms of big policy but in terms of accountability,
right? We want to hear Trump sucks and Trump has a small dick
and you know, we're going to humiliate Trump once we get back
into power and it's not going to be sunshine and roses. We want
to hear that [__] So, there's clearly an appetite
there and I'm I'm sure you would agree with it even if you don't
think we should go full bore Trump. But then just like have the
conversation about what you think might based on the circumstances
such as they are right now that could contribute to Democratic
control. I agree with you that you can't set anything in stone,
but you're not in a position to do that anyway. I'm not in a
position to do that and I'm the biggest creator of the bunch.
None of us are, right? >> But I know you're right. Things
could change. But I think that was what he was interested in
talking about even if you disagreed with his preferred methods
of demagoguery and campaigning on lock them >> Okay. There
is no I mean all these pundits and commentators and the endless
chatter Sure. And and maybe you could have maybe you could have
just said that. Take your If if what you're saying is it's not
even worth having the conversation for academic purposes, then
maybe the conversation would have been more fruitful if you just
said, "Rashad, I I disagree with your proffered strategies. I
understand what you're looking for. It just simply can't be provided.
We are we are in a situation where we have to play politics election
by election, minute by minute, move by move, inch by inch and
we can't see Hutches, sorry. This is This is
It's so [__] up that society is doing exactly what
I said. Oh, he's he's saying exactly what I said. Like there
are arguments from Hutches' side. He just doesn't make them.
He just dismisses you and restates what he Right? He doesn't
make like an argument. He doesn't try to convince you back. He
just dismisses you and restates what he already thought. That's
what's condescending. That's what like makes it It makes it seem
like he's not interested in having any conversation at all. He
can't update his own mental model with what you've said, so he
just dismisses you and then talks about what he wants again.
>> You know, that many feet. Like we're we're we're operating
in a bit of a fog and all we can see is the next step. And so,
that's where I'm focused. And so, there's really nothing to talk
about as far as what's 10 steps ahead. >> But I did say
that though. I did say that throughout our conversation. No,
you didn't. You just No, you didn't. You just read the trip say
that. No, you didn't say that. You didn't say that at all. You
just read what the trip one said to you, which is a a logical
inference of what you've said, right, in the past. That could
be, but you haven't laid it out for the other person. So, the
other person only hears the dismissal,
and they don't hear your idea.
So, it's possible that Hutch just doesn't have like a theory
of mind he that he can't con- conceive of like the the thinking
of other people and how they don't have his precise thoughts,
so maybe he just can't communicate them. But, I don't think that's
what it is, >> that as far as what's 10 steps ahead. But,
I did say that, though. I did say that throughout our conversation.
Remember that part? I was I was pushing back against Gaslighting
again.
>> that um I mean, first of all, I felt like he was a bit
all over the place because like in one breath he was at times
100% you know, I brought up I was like, why are we overcomplicating
this? And I or I was saying the same thing. Like, we're coming
we're it seems like there's just like this this sense of urgency
and >> Oh, sure. I saw the Weebs Gangs PFP. I I saw it.
>> of like impending doom. Like, we got to do something.
Like, we got to figure this out, otherwise they're going to keep
like dominating us. And my whole thing was I was I was pushing
back against the framing, the narrative. It's all wrong. All
of that is wrong. They're not dominating right now. They are
in an incredibly weakened position right now.
But, you're just saying that. So, I think they're in an incredibly
weak position because of this.
Now, you said, I think they're in a weak
um in the in the polls right now. We're doing good in elections.
Rashad responded with a reason why he thinks that's the case
and why that won't last. I think currently we're we're basically
seeing the Trump is bad and I don't think that will last through
to a general election. Cuz we've seen traditionally it doesn't.
Well, and also I don't think it's indicative of Democratic messaging
at all, which is what they're talking about, right? And and Hutch
didn't respond. He just said, yeah, but we're winning right now.
>> And we already know what's winning elections. And so,
I found his response when I was just like, why are you adding
this like oh, we have to run on
Uh Drama 101, you're just wrong. Feel free to join the Discord
and make any argument about why it's okay for Hutch to make faces
that imply the other person talking is a when those people are
his friends and fail to make any argument. It's snakey as [__]
And it's rude. Everybody else makes the arguments back. Hutch
makes snarky faces to his chat so they can see that he thinks
he's right and then he dismisses.
on um really like strong demagoguery. I was like what why do
what are you talking about? Like we already Like we have a blueprint
for how to win elections right now and he kept and then he would
push back and say stuff like like you know I I brought up Spanberger
and Mike Sherrill and then he was like
You started with Spanberger and Mike Sherrill. That he he like
laughed. He like literally laughed. He's like that does He basically
said like those races don't matter. And then when I unpacked
that a little bit he kind No, he didn't. He He didn't just say
they don't matter. He He said, "Here's my argument for why they
might be misleading." And walked that back like 10 minutes later.
You even got him You even got him on the why does Mumdani matter
but they don't? Like yeah, I I totally agree. I'm I'm not here
to I am not here to >> Mumdani isn't even doing what he's
suggesting though. Mumdani did not No, no, no, no on um like
demagoguery on Donald Trump. Like there was He wasn't saying
that the solution to this is Mumdani.
He didn't say that. The only thing they were talking about was
basically how good is Democratic rhetoric right now and what
is our plan for the future? How are we going to create the thousand-year
progressive Reich, okay? And
And Hutch could uh Hutch is like Hutch doesn't understand the
conversation that took place. Again, some of that rhetoric but
he was very surgically focused on affordability and laser focus.
Yeah, yeah. I I totally agree and I and I thought and many times
you had him cornered and at many points Rashad contradicted himself.
Like I'm not here to to simp for Rashad's position as he articulated
it. What I would I think that there was a better And this is
This is the unfortunate thing, okay? And I don't think I really
don't think that this is good for Hutch long term.
Because unfortunately he will end up talking to other people
and he will if you guys aren't keeping him in check when he fails
to address arguments, when he fails to like integrate what somebody
said and make a coherent argument back, if you don't ever check
him, he's going to walk into other places. Like, when he walked
into that chorus panel and got his have kit head caved in by
Dickers, Fabian Liberty, and like Prime Kai and Fabian Liberty,
okay? Prime Kai and Fabian Liberty are like the foils
to make other ideologies look r- and Hutch went into that conversation
and got dominated.
Okay?
Are we serious? Hutch walked in that conversation got dominated
by like the jobbers that are brought along to make liberals look
like DBZ characters, okay? That's Well, and Dickers, I don't
think of Dickers that same way. I probably wouldn't even think
of the other two that same way if I knew them at all. But
But like
that's what's going to happen. You're going to keep letting Hutch
embarrass himself when he goes to other spaces because you won't
you don't check him ever. is like when when he heard cuz I I
heard it as a as a member of the audience while I was driving
and I was thinking, man, you guys really are talking past each
other cuz he would say, "What about the future? What about, you
know, um sustained control?" And you were saying, "We know what's
winning elections right now in the age of Trump." And he's like,
"Well, what about after Trump?" And it was just like, I think
if you would just said, "I just I not only reject various premises,
I reject the entire premise of this conversation because we cannot
we can't even cogently
intelligently have a conversation about doing what needs to be
done to build sustained majorities in Congress and um you know,
uh sustained control of the White House because all we can do
is play it move by move. That's where we are if >> But
didn't I say that though? Wasn't I I I No, I don't >> Maybe
I Maybe I shouted I don't remember that. I don't I don't remember
that. But maybe I listened to the whole thing. I don't remember
that. I remember you certainly taking issue. I remember you certainly
going back to you and and Guy both what's winning elections now,
but I don't think you connected the dots. You certainly didn't
do it for me and I don't think you connected it to his satisfaction,
Neil's satisfaction, or even Pisco's satisfaction about like
drawing the connection there like, "Hey, Rashad, it's not just
that I disagree with your specific approaches. We can't even
have the conversation. It is impossible.
All we can do, the only thing the Democratic Party can do is
play the game move by move. Whatever we were able to do in the
past to have decades-long control of the House of Representative,
those days are done. We can't do that. It's not possible. All
we can do is what You know what it reminds me of, Josiah? It
reminds me of like um It reminds me of like a uh like a Wall
Street trader
who you know how they have their their client Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Huh. If the If dude was good faith and humble, he would
have said, "Hey, guys, how should we hold Republicans accountable?"
Bro.
Uh somehow this audience has been trained to expect people to
like grovel at Hutch's feet.
Like literally grovel at the feet of this mental invalid.
I I don't even know what to say, man. >> Like a Wall Street
trader
you know how they have their their client list. And uh like it
just imagine a Wall Street trader that claims to have like special
insight into where the market's going to be like 8 years from
now. And you know, tell That's not what he did. You're totally
straw manning him. You are a total [__] loser. It's
literally not what he did at all.
It's literally not what he did at all. >> Telling their
client, you know, we need to do better than just like investing
in an index fund. Like we need to beat the market by 10x. And
here's my plan to how to do that.
It's not about beating the market by 10x. And by the way, most
major like most are like cutting edge trade cutting edge trade
firms do try to create like crazy amounts of wealth. They're
not looking for like a 5% bump, right? They are looking for those
inside edges all the time. Yes. Like everything that follows
after that sentence is because you have no [__] idea
what is going to be salient for voters in 2028. And there's no
evidence
I would argue
that the reason some people got behind Andrew Yang
Andrew Yang is the one of the biggest goobers on planet Earth,
okay? He there's almost nothing that is like overtly likable
about him except for how earnest he is. All right? The thing
that made people line up behind him a little bit was the fact
that he had some coherent vision that took the future into account
and was saying these are going to be the
I do think there are parts of Andrew Yang that you should be
thinking about as automation continues to take jobs away as offshoring
continues to take jobs away
everything Andrew Yang has said will become more prescient over
time, okay?
That is what you need to do. You need to have a an overall narrative,
an overall like thing that you're that you're preaching that
you believe in, right? And the Democratic Party doesn't have
that. The Democratic Party has like we
we're not like them. We're we're we're the party of facts or
something. It's like there is no coherent narrative. It's at
best it's like we are the people who want to be respectful and
and have like good lives for most of the people, right? We want
to we want to respect other people's ideologies, we want to respect
their race, we want to respect the things about them that they
can't change, and we're going to try to make America work given
that it's like a multicultural, multi-ethnic society.
I would say maybe that that is kind of like the party of that
that's sort of like what Democrats are about, right? I'm not
going to say it's like nothing and that is there are parts of
that that are noble. I don't disagree with, right? But it's not
a message that's like going to net you new voters. It doesn't
work anymore. You've you've done it. I think you've reached the
zenith of it and I don't think it's really working anymore,
That's not working, man. >> It's at all right now. Not
that you have to abandon that. I don't think you should abandon
that at >> That his He just need more elements. >> prescription
of the Democrats running aggressively first and foremost on demagoguery,
there's nothing to support this, Josiah. There's nothing to support
this and there's plenty of evidence to support um not doing the
strategy. Like the Democrats did not run on on demagoguery in
2018, and they had a blue wave election, okay? They specifically
avoided talking about Trump in 2018. I don't know if you remember
those midterms, but this was reported on. Demagoguery, it's basically
doing like personal attacks on your opponents and stuff. Um hold
on, I need to I need to hear what he's saying here, one second.
>> doing the strategy. Like the Democrats did not run on
on demagoguery in 2018, and they had a blue wave election, okay?
They specifically
Did Hutch just tell me did he just try to tell me that there
was no
in 2018?
I somehow find that hard to
I personally would find that almost impossible to believe.
Now, did Democrats not There's no way that Democrats just weren't
talking about Trump. What? They had to have been engaging in
demagoguery.
Now, you might say it's justifiable, so it's not demagoguery,
but it's like it's still attacking this guy's reputation. >> specifically
avoided
fearmongering on him. in 2018. I don't know if you remember I
don't believe that. I don't believe that. I don't believe that.
What the [__] is he saying?
I Do I just remember like the 2018 2016 2018 election as like
way different?
Do I just have no [__] idea what happened in the
2018 election? I do think I I do I do think there was an implicit
anti-Trump message there. And you look, maybe maybe this would
be useful to have a follow-up conversation with Loch Sia here,
you know, not just parsing through the data, but to be like,
"Hey, Loch Sia, to what extent is anti-Trump sentiment contributing
to the Democratic Party's successes?" Now, my assumption is
like half of it. My assumption is if it's not the single most
important thing, I'd probably concede that affordability is,
that anti-Trump sentiment is not a minor contributing >> That's
politics. >> Democrats' success in 2025 and 2026. Isaiah,
you know, a big big part of the reason why he won in '92
is because the public had soured on George W. H.W. Bush after
he after he said he wouldn't raise their taxes. George W. Bush
winning in 2000 was in part uh So,
you're he like loses context. The reason Josiah is saying this
to you, Hutch, is because he's trying to make the argument for
what Rashad was saying, which is, "Hey, we shouldn't sit on our
laurels. Yeah, we're winning now, but that's mostly based on
our opponents being very bad. Like they're people don't like
what they're doing with the country. They don't like how high
expenses are and stuff, right?" So, it's based on our opponents
being bad, Trump being bad, people getting shot in the streets,
okay? That's what our That's what our, you know, it's not even
the favorability cuz Democrats are still really unfavorable,
but that's like how we're winning elections right now is basically
people are seeing the Trump admin and they're voting against
that. And I also think there's another element, which is the
cult cult of personality people in elections outside where Donald
Trump's not involved, they don't really get involved personally,
right? People don't care. That's something that's happened with
their party is midterms they're like super disfavored because
they have taken in like so many low-information, like low-concern
cohorts that people just basically aren't voting in midterms,
I think. I that's that's what I I suspect.
So, anyway, that that's all to say that like there are reasons
your advantages are building up and they're they're quicksand.
They're not real advantages,
That's the argument he's making. So, when you say, "Well, that's
the way it works all the time," it's like, "Well, but he wants
to make something more stable. He wants to build advantages that
are more stable." That's what he wants to try to do. So, the
fact that it happens all the time, if you just want to say, if
you want to be anti-intellectual about this and say, "Well, I
don't think I actually don't think you can build up any long-term
advantage with the American people. I think it's always going
to ping-pong." So, I think basically trying to ping-pong harder,
this would be an argument, right? I By the way, on the fly, just
came to me. I just want to focus on ping-ponging harder so that
we lose less in in the pongs back to them and we gain more in
the pings back to us, okay?
That would be an argument.
If that was his argument, that would be at least somewhat coherent.
Maybe not even correct, maybe not correct at all. I might still
totally disagree with it, but it would be like a thought process.
With him, he just goes he just gives you a fact that is not an
argument. Nobody's going to say no, politics America doesn't
swing back and forth between two parties.
Nobody's going to say you gave me a like an unfalsifiable statement.
It's not even an opinion. >> to well, I mean, I don't know
about that so much because Clinton was pretty popular. No, I
I I I understand that that is part of politics. That's why I
think you got to be careful about when
again, and maybe maybe this is just me making assumptions based
on what you say. When you talk about Democrats not campaigning
on anti-Trump, I agree with you that they're not explicitly doing
so, but I think you must acknowledge
or I would hope you would acknowledge, but maybe Laksha has evidence
to the contrary that anti-Trump sentiment is absolutely
contributing to the success of these Democrats. Even if they're
not if even if they're not campaigning on Trump bad, Trump bad
being the fog misting the air, they don't even have to say it.
They don't >> what you're saying. I understand what you're
saying. Like the negative sentiment of Trump is for sure a large
factor in what is driving these enormous successes for the Democratic
Party. My whole my whole thing is that you know, and it's not
that they don't ever say negative things about Trump. That's
not true. I'm not saying that either. I'm
the extent to which Rashad wanted to take it to make it the centerpiece
of the Democratic Party messaging right now. He was saying that
the Democratic Party broadly
needs to start running on Republicans are evil and they're out
to kill you and ruin your lives. That was his prescription. And
there's no evidence that this type of strategy is what is connecting
with voters right now. None. There's nothing to support that.
It is a very ego-centric
ego-centric
myopic kind of view of things. He, Rashad, I would argue in that
moment is just projecting. He he He wants to hear Republican
He wants to hear Democratic politicians say that because he feels
very strongly about these things and he's projecting that attitude
on the electorate. Why would So, when they had the conversation
about why Democrats are winning, he did not talk about demagoguery.
Hutch is introducing this because it allows him something to
push back against, but that's that's like a different point that's
outside of the scope of the conversation. There's another problem
when talking with him is he at this probably everybody does this
is sometimes you'll be mixing arguments together you'll like
pull something in from somewhere else, right? I know you >> That's
all I was saying. >> I know you got to go soon, so Yeah.
Yeah, I'll let you go. >> make sense? Does that make sense
what what I was suggesting there that I I would have like to
have I guess I would have like to have heard you engage more
on that while shutting down his proper strategy even if it was
just say, "Hey, Rashad, I get what you're getting at in terms
of sustained control. I don't think your approach will do it,
but the truth is I don't know what it will take to do it either
because we just there's no way to predict and and I understand
you're looking at the past at previous periods of sustained control
and maybe we need to do a forensic audit about what worked then,
but that may not just that just may no longer be possible in
this information age and in this political age. It may be that
we are we are in an age of just swapping back and forth and maybe
the age of even two-term presidencies are going to become less
frequent. You know, we just yeah. >> maybe for the rest
of your life and I'm not saying that you need to be happy about
that, but I am saying that you need to be prepared for that possibility
and yeah.
I would say anybody who's not prepared to try to make the opposite
the reality is not working hard enough.
That that's how it seems to me, right? Stay engaged and to not
get apathetic and to not completely take the black pill. What
if this this is back and forth for the next 40 years? It's
But I but I guarantee but I guarantee you there's going to be
way worse outcomes if you take the black pill and, you know,
begin to become apathetic and complacent and disengaged.
No, I agree. That's literally they're arguing for the opposite.
They're literally arguing for the opposite. They have been the
whole time. >> why I was I was pleased that Rashad said
like his as much as, you know, That is just a total straw man.
Josiah has never advocated for that. Josiah has always said the
opposite of that. That is like you just I don't even know who
the [__] you're talking to right now. Certainly we're
not talking to Rashad. Rashad certainly doesn't seem apathetic
or disengaged. >> criticisms of Gavin Newsom that he said,
you know, he unlike Hassan and others, you know, that he's committing
to voting for the the the Democratic candidate no matter who
it is. So again, that's all I'm saying is I I felt that there
was like a a if if not a productive conversation to be had, a
way for that part of the conversation to end productively.
Um and it's easy to play armchair quarterback, you know, when
you're in the moment, but I think if you had said to him what
you said to me in the in the same combination of words, there
would have been more potential for a lightbulb moment um and
kind of like an agree to disagree situation rather than, you
know, what happened. Um because I'm certainly more satisfied
with your answer than I was your answers yesterday. And his answers
had me immensely dissatisfied.
The only reason you got those answers out of Hutch is because
you explicitly forced him to say those things.
Right? Nobody's going to go into a conversation with Hutch and
say, "Hey, you have to you have to explain everything you think
to me." Right? Like nobody's going to This almost will never
happen. People will go, "I suspect you have a different thought
in your head for why you're saying this. Could you expand on
that thought that I suspect you have?" Josiah can do that cuz
Josiah has talked to Hutch before. Josiah probably knows some
of the arguments and like Josiah had to give, right? You just
heard it. Josiah I to give the argument Hutch should be making
and then Hutch went, "Man, perhaps perhaps we'll be ping-ponging
for the rest of your
But Hutch never said the words. Josiah had to convince himself
of Hutch's >> Um for the reasons that you articulated there,
cuz it seemed like there were times he totally contradicted himself.
Well, yeah, let's um let's dive into it again. I'm sure this
will keep coming up, but I I um text me when your uh Newsom video
goes up, cuz I want to watch that [__] Congrat- Okay,
so then that's how that ends, all right? I kind of almost want
to follow up and just watch Hutch get yelled at again. I'm not
going to lie to you guys. I sort of just want to like pull it
back and listen to Josiah first come in one more time, now that
I have all that context. Now just hear you say I'm like way far
behind, but that I am too online, that I'm one of the two online
craft. You unpack that for me. I'm just going to list No, but
hang on. Hang on. I'm going off of what Pisco
>> So, Josiah came in a little bit heated. A a little bit
heated. A little bit >> Pisco said, okay, Pisco said something
about you maybe saying that we should ignore the courts.
Oh, I've talked in the past about
This is a debate that I've had for years. I'm not entirely sure
that I think the president of the United States, no matter who
it is, is obligated to always obey the Supreme Court, because
president and this is it's a notion called non-acquiescence,
and it really has its genesis for all intents and purposes during
the Civil
So, I just I now that we have watched a little bit of this, I'm
just going to say, so Hut- sorry, Josiah starts to explain his
idea. Watch Hutch as Josiah >> the Supreme Court, because
president and this is it's a notion called non-acquiescence,
and it really Total dismissal. Total dismissal on its >> has
its genesis for all intents and purposes during the Civil War,
because President Lincoln dis-
Now now now look at the chat's reaction when he did this.
Too online, lmao. I can't with these [__] stirrers,
lol. All I hear is yes, Jesus Christ." I don't get on Hutch for
like the the chat I'm not going to say the chat's unhinged. The
chat's doing exactly they're just signaling for your opinion,
which you just signaled to them. They just went, "Yeah, we see
it too, Hutch. Yeah, we see it, too."
This had the audacity.
Audacity to imply that somebody else's audience was being signaled
against them, put against him.
When he does it explicitly to people he considers his friends.
And trust me, if this was just the way Hutch did content and
he did this from time to time, and everybody can do this from
time to time. He does it constantly, and then he went out of
his way to let his friend be attacked by someone else because
he couldn't even make the argument that he thought it was happening
to him correctly. Okay? That's what pisses me off. It's regarded
a court order by a Chief Justice Taney about um habeas corpus.
And his logic was at the time like, "If I obey this order, it's
basically going to jeopardize the war effort. Do I have to forego
my duty to, you know, take care of that all the other laws be
faithful
um for the sake of this one?" And so, it's it's something that's
been been debated by judicial scholars for
it's something that yeah, I I absolutely think about because
the the the what the entailment there is that the Supreme Court
is the boss of Congress and the president. And it's actually
intended to be the weakest of the three branches, weaker than
the president, certainly weaker than Congress. So, yes, this
is something that >> Can you give me a real-world application?
Give me a hypothetical where you think it might be appropriate.
Like a realistic kind of real-world application in the modern
context.
Oh, that I probably couldn't give you one offhand. I don't think
I've ever called for non-acquiescence in like the modern time.
I can't think of a like a single example, but it it's a philosophical
notion that there are Supreme Court orders that in theory, I
think the president should just ignore. Like again, you know,
like civil war and things of that nature. Well, I mean
Tell me how it came up in the context of you talking about it
recently. >> there's one There is one There is one modern
example. Well, no, because Pixel and I talk about this [__]
all the time because we I don't I don't understand why you can't
engage in the actual conversation. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Obviously, he's not talking about just willy-nilly ignoring the
court. I don't understand why you can't engage in the actual
conversation. >> Oh, there's one There This is a deeply
terrible argument. Sorry, Josiah. There is one There is one modern
example. Well, no, because
Lopsided Pixel because he'll be embarrassed. That is true. >> Pixel
and I talk about this [__] all the time because we
talk about balance of power, separation of powers, which branch
is supposed to be dominant over the others. This is These are
like common conversations that we've had. Um just like structural
uh conversations about the system of government. But, there's
one example, actually, I can think of where I flirted with
Five's based. They're all dismissing Josiah. Sorry, a bunch of
them are dismissing Josiah now. Why have a court at all if there's
so much debate about >> during the Biden administration
um about the debt ceiling. Okay? So, I I can't remember all the
details
Leave the philosophy crap to Andrew
Brain damaged. Brain dead.
I Maybe the answer is just like to
to consistently stream to a totally brain dead audience, you
just have to be brain dead yourself, perhaps. >> details
at the time. So, it was like 2022, 2023
when we needed to lift the debt ceiling and there was a potential
government shutdown because uh the Republicans weren't going
to
um you know, necessarily give the votes and They are coequal
branches. I think Josiah specifically responds to this. >> was
a lot of debate about whether or not Biden should mint a trillion-dollar
coin or something like that in order to knock off enough debt
so that we we have some room before we hit the debt ceiling.
Um and there was a debate about whether or not the Supreme Court
would force President Biden to um uh default on our debt. If
if you can't if So, Hutch is doing this thing where he's basically
like showing total
to his friend's idea, right? He's I actually haven't been watching
his face all that much. >> so that we the trillion-dollar
coin or something like that in order to knock off enough debt
so that we we have some room before we hit the debt ceiling.
Um and there was a debate about whether or not the Supreme Court
would force
President Biden to um uh default on our debt. If if you can't
if you can't come to an agreement to satisfy the statutory obligations
to raise the raise It's not involuntary, because when he disagrees,
and you know he disagrees, when somebody says something he disagrees
with, he makes a face. It's not involuntary.
It's like or if it's involuntary, it signals something. It's
not random. >> suspend the debt ceiling. If the Supreme
Court said um uh yeah, we got to default on our debt because
the president is still spending Sorry, I corrected you on the
involuntary thing. It might be involuntary. It's not random is
what I meant to say. >> money that he's not congressionally
authorized to use, um maybe the president should just ignore
them and continue to do it. You're going to have to try to order
me to default on the national debt and trigger a global economic
catastrophe. Besides And and Lawrence Tribe, Harvard Professor
Lawrence Tribe, one of the most reputable in the business, also
made the case that the president might just want to ignore what
the Supreme Court says. Listen, you're my boy, and I love you.
Already immediately condescending. Just want you to know that.
The pause, even more condescending.
Appreciate that, buddy. That's really online, buddy. That's
Absolute dismissal. This is I It's funny because I think Pisco
and Josiah's
intolerance for this comes from the same place, cuz we're about
to watch Josiah's response, okay? But the intolerance comes from
the same
I'm showing you respect by taking knowledge that I've gained
through hours and hours and hours and hours of reading, watching,
paying attention, synthesizing, arguing with my contemporaries,
reading, watching, arguing, reading, watching, arguing. I'm I'm
literally distilling this down into something you could understand.
And you just had the audacity to condescend to me and not listen
to my answer, not listen to the thing I'm telling you. I I understand
how that that would be so enraging, right? You're like the expert
on something, somebody comes to you they're like, "Hey, what
do you think about this?" And you take some some opinion you
have that you've had arguments back and forth with tons of smart
people. And you give them this and they just go, "Huh, that's
pretty crazy, man. You're kind of crazy."
It's like Uh I I understand why you get mad, okay? I'll let it
play now. >> really online. You know, You you you you asked
me Wait, you asked me for an example. What what the hell does
that mean? You're talking about ignoring the Supreme Court, Josiah.
This is a really online not
Yeah, the the conversation was about why you might ignore the
Supreme Court, not whether or not it was okay to ignore the Supreme
Court. It's about why. serious
Okay? Like if you start advocating for a Why would it stop there?
He knows that.
It's Josiah.
He literally knows that, bro. Okay? Okay, it's And I just want
to I just want to remind you cuz it's very important. All of
Every answer Hutch does like this to somebody when they when
they basically lay out a reason a reason for their their position
and he goes back to saying, "I just think I just think that's
really silly to talk about." It's all some flavor of, "Yes, I
did have breakfast this morning." >> does that mean? You're
talking about ignoring the Supreme Court, Josiah. This is a really
online not serious thing. Okay? Like if you start advocating
for a Why would it stop there? At that point if you just ignore
the court that blatantly, that kind of way, why would you stop
there? And at that point at that point you are speed >> But
Josiah, are you telling me there are no circumstances under no
circumstances
can the President of the United States or Congress disregard
the Supreme Court? You can't think of any. >> no, yes,
but in the shut the [__] up. It's just a matter of
where the line is drawn. So you invoke your Hey, [__]
your condescension, bro. You invoked You invoked the Civil War.
Josiah, you invoked the Civil War.
You're right. So there's a line, Hutch. Yes, Civil War. >> again,
[__] your holier-than-thou
Just now you asked me for a specific example Were we in a Civil
War during Biden? Were we in a Civil War during Biden? You asked
me for a specific example outside of a Civil War. And I admitted
that there was one that I was flirting
>> And by the way, and by the way, it's By the way, as
soon as as soon as Josiah said the thing that was obviously true,
the entire chat flipped on Hutch on a
Okay, not Hello It's Harrison, but the rest of the chat all essentially
A ton of them flipped on Josiah almost immediately. The second
Hutch had that that thought-terminating thing, and they like
Josiah reasonably, and he actually got upset about it, ton of
the chat >> me at Highly educated judicial scholars all
I understand. There's a lot of Lawrence Tribe, famous not serious
>> It's not serious. You're not thinking about it. Like
you invoked the last time that happened. >> Oh my god.
Oh my god. >> I'm letting you talk, bro. I'm letting you
talk. You invoked that
You invoked >> spending all this time condescending me.
I answered you in good faith. I don't give a [__]
if you don't think I don't give a [__] if you don't
think that it's a serious example. In good faith I I'm playing
with you. It's banter. It's banter. Chill. >> It's not
No, it's not banter. It's not
Do you see? It's It's all I mean, I don't want to overanalyze
this cuz people are going to say I'm I'm like going crazy, but
it's all
it's all just gaslighting. Oh, it's just banter. Well, maybe
not is like half serious. It wasn't banter. It wasn't banter.
You sincerely believe that. You sincerely condescended to him.
You dismissed his points. Yes.
I hate to say it. I really hate to say it, okay?
But I'm sorry.
If you think I'm I'm going to get in so much trouble, but I have
to I have to speak my mind. I have to speak my mind.
I don't want to get anybody else in fights or trouble, but if
you think this had nothing to do with the stuff that just happened
with Pisco, you're out of your [__] mind, okay? It
obviously is is Josiah watching the show from afar
seeing what was just done to Pisco when Pisco is kind because
there's only so many ways you can handle somebody doing this,
right? Basically, Hutch doesn't understand or is incapable of
understanding Josiah's argument.
There's a couple ways that you could either call them out on
being a piece of [__] in the moment, which Josiah
just You can totally ignore it and go, "Haha, you're guess so,
buddy." and eventually just walk away. Or you could like sort
of Socratically navigate around and try to help them understand
why they're not getting it. And Pisco picks that option. Josiah
just picked the other option, right?
Josiah I feel like Josiah has to understand it's very very smart
on his part that this is the only other way to deal with Hutch
and it it just has to be more direct. Pisco was being too kind
and he got called rude. He said that people said he was like
an [__] He wasn't.
He wasn't.
And I I think Josiah saw all of this and was like, "Hey, buddy,
you're getting a little too big for your boots over there, okay?
Get a little too big for your britches over there." Cuz Hutch
I feel like Hutch was lobbing grenades at Pisco that episode,
too.
And I don't think you could you can't be you know, you can't
look at your people around you and think of them as equals and
do this. And then when they come back at you with a similar energy
like curl up into a small bean and say, "Well, I was just it
was just banter." No, it wasn't. It wasn't cuz he he put the
effort into make a real argument back to you to treat you like
an equal and you didn't return the the that kindness. You didn't
return the respect. But it is banter. But you're saying I know
you're being I know you well enough to I know you well enough
to know when you're being serious and you just >> I'm being
half serious. Let me Let me Let me respond to it then. Let me
respond to it. >> Wait a minute. If you're just going to
condes- You're being belligerent >> just going to condes-
We need Destiny to
That chatter needs to end themselves immediately. That chatter
needs to If you ever watch this Chromaton 4538
leave the planet. Send me? No, thank
What? Are you pulling out of the conversation then? I won't condescend
you. I will be so nice and civil.
Then proceed. Okay. You brought up last time the non-acquiescence
in the context of a civil war. I've
But then see this is this is the this is the gaslighting, right?
Hutch will not just say, "I was wrong. I was condescending. That
was wrong of me to do to you because you're my friend." He can't
do it. He's incapable of doing it. That's the answer. I I was
condescending to you. I was. I asked you for an example. I didn't
listen. That was condescending. I apologize. Shouldn't have done
that to my friend.
But what he did here was say, "Man, the I I just do think it's
online cuz the last example you could give me was a civil war."
And and Josiah sitting here like, "No, no, no. I gave you a current
example that legal scholars are scholars are arguing could be
a valid use of non
That's the current example. And like if you don't want to have
that conversation, then don't ask me for a current example. But
I just gave you Do not ask me for a current example and then
ignore me. Uh crazy that Hutch is doing the exact thing he hates
in far
Uh I don't even know if he Man, I don't
I don't know if
I don't know if Hutch has opinions >> Obviously. That is
a totally different calculation. If we are at the point where
we're in a civil war, then dude
But Josiah, here's the thing.
Hutch doesn't understand that other he This is the problem when
dealing with somebody when you when somebody has like a disability.
How do I What's a good analogy for this? It's like imagine humans
could fly.
and Hutch basically Hutch can't fly. And so all of the other
humans around Hutch
Cuz they don't want Hutch to feel bad. And then Hutch is like
trying to style on somebody and show how much higher they can
jump than him. Or sorry, how much higher he can jump than them.
And they go to jump and they don't quite jump as high. But all
the humans know they can fly and Hutch is being like a total
dick about being able to jump really high. Like he's he Now he's
sitting here. He's jumping up and down and he's saying, "Look,
look. This is all because you gave you couldn't give me a current
example. You couldn't give me a modern example." No, Hutch, you
just didn't listen. He gave you a modern example, which you asked
him for after this happened in the conversation. And guess what?
Because Josiah can fly, Josiah remembers the progression of the
And so he's going to remind you of the progression of the conversation.
But so many bets like all bets are off. Like, you know, you try
to preserve the system as much as you can and you you know, you
at the same time you're you're in a war with people that want
to take it over and maybe do like a fascist takeover and do like
a coup or whatever and like basically destroy the system. At
that point you have to make all kinds of compromises. I mean,
I'm like of course like there were illiberal things that happened
when we were fighting the civil war, but we're not there right
now. We are we are like 20 steps removed from that. And I just
want to ask you if you think that it's a realistic solution
to just start ignoring the Supreme Court.
So this is all like this has to be this is doubling down on Josiah
off and being condescending because you didn't listen to the
example he gave. You gave the one that you he disagreed with
and he went, "Oh jeez, you know, I don't think I can come up
with one." And that's like an okay point. Oh wait, no, I remember
now. I did have one. We do have one from like a a respected legal
scholar that that's the that's the thing that convinced me on
this. And then he gives it to you and you don't listen, you ignore
it and you just start talking about how crazy it is to base non-acquiescence
on the Civil War again. And I'm just asking you like do you not
think at that point that the right wing in this country are going
to take up arms and just Patronizing is when being asked for
specifics instead of being based on vibes. Only when it's Pisco.
Only when it's Pisco asking for specifics is it patronizing or
rude or mean to your friends. When it's Hutch doing it, which
by the way that's not even what's happening here, but when it's
Hutch doing it you you're totally willing to excuse it. Awesome.
So cool, man.
Oh, Hutch is doing it? Well, when Hutch does it it's awesome.
When Pisco does it he's kind of a dick.
It's just on like Donkey Kong at that point, right?
That That is a possibility. That's what I don't you want to avoid
that? Don't you want to avoid that, bro? Do you remember how
this topic just came up?
Josiah is floating off the ground slowly. He's slowly rising
into the air.
He's slowly rising into the air, okay?
You asked me about about me saying that you were too
Right. So, I asked you a question, a very specific question.
You said, "Well, it's based off something I heard from Pisco
about the Supreme Court." And I said, "Well, there is this notion
called non-acquiescence and it's happened in the past. It's just
very, very rare and it's something that's being discussed and
has been discussed for centuries by judicial scholars." And I
gave you a specific example. Then you wanted to to on non-acquiescence
and you said, "Well, why would you be talking about that with
Well, again, Pisco and I have conversations like a lot broad
abstract conversations
about separation of powers and checks and balances. Pisco and
I go flying around all the
We we like we go and we fly around all the time and just chill
in the air, >> all the time. >> Right. And then when
you asked me for what non-civil war example could I possibly
conceive of about where non-acquiescence might be permissible,
I said it it I remembered the one about the debt ceiling. Yeah.
Because if we defaulted on our debt, it would trigger a domestic
and global economic catastrophe
that would probably make the Great Depression look like a walk
in the park, which is why at the time there were judicial scholars
like Lawrence Tribe and others suggesting that maybe
if the the president forces the issue to the Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court says, "You need to default on the debt because
you didn't statutorily meet the terms of raising or suspending
the debt ceiling," that the president, for the sake of the domestic
and global economy, should just give the court the finger and
keep uh spending money to pay off the debt. That I said that
was an example where of course I considered it. And you responded
with the most unhinged, condescending rant, "How dare you even
think in such a scenario
Dude, it's just so it's just perfect. It's like actually exactly
what had to be said to Hutch. It's perfect. And honestly, about
the most kind way it could be delivered.
Like, hey, do you Bro, I do I do feel like I could feel Josiah
raise off the ground a little bit as he's like, "Do you remember
how this conversation started?"
He just He just walked through cuz cuz Josiah can fly. He can
maintain multiple He can juggle multiple balls in his mind at
the same time, okay? He's capable of juggling multiple concepts
at the same time. So, he remembers how the conversation started,
the progression it took, and why he's so upset at the way Hutch
has responded, and he says all of it out to him in a way that's
essentially undeniable.
about violating or disregarding the Supreme Court. And if we
didn't, wouldn't the right, you know, raise up in rebellion?
I'm not suggesting
that that is something that any president, Democrat or Republican,
invoke on the regular, but I can imagine some extraordinary crisis
like either a civil war or a domestic or global economic catastrophe,
where the court could probably be ignored for the greater good.
Now, having reiterated that all again, do you really think that
responding the way you did was appropriate?
Listen, the context Listen, what you're saying right now is reasonable
to me, okay?
What he said before, you just didn't
You are You are implying with this that he didn't say that to
you before, which is wrong.
You are refusing to admit that you were wrong by being more wrong,
doubling down on being wrong. Hutch, everybody else can see you're
wrong except for you and people similarly shackled to the ground.
Everybody else who can fly, which is almost all of us, we can
all see that you're wrong.
Josiah just demonstrated exactly how and why you're wrong, and
your first reaction is to go, "Well, now that you say all those
things like I could maybe understand."
No, he said that. You just ignored it. If you're helping If you're
just If you're shutting down the conversation, Josiah Josiah,
let me talk, okay? The context of all of this was we I was in
a debate last night with Rashad, and Pisco started to to to do
the thing that he does me where he like he likes tried he like
tries
This is anything Pisco did is totally irrelevant. Regardless
of what you thought, Josiah came in and was totally fine talking
through what you thought. He might have been annoyed that you
were calling him two-online, but he was perfectly willing to
talk through. He didn't lose his temper until you until he was
explaining what he was like thinking and and the conversation
and you couldn't process it and you just went that's really online,
bro. Then he lost his temper.
So anything anything Hutch could possibly say about Pisco here
is wrong. >> to trap me in hypocrisy or something like
that. He brought Oh, Pisco is trying to be a bad friend to me.
Just like Destiny said, Pisco is trying to be a bad friend to
me just like Destiny said. He's being a bad friend.
made last night with Rashad and Pisco started to do to do the
thing that he does with me where he like he likes tried he like
tries to trap me in hypocrisy or something like that. He brought
you into this and he said uh Josiah's been talking about like
ignoring the court. That's what he said to me. So that was my
impression, right? That's what I'm thinking, right? And so you
come in and and and then you you talk about the Civil War and
then you mention this other thing. I'm still in my head thinking
like, you know, this is not the only application that that it's
come up. I mean, are there other times where you suggested that
possibly Biden should have ignored the Supreme Court or we should
or the next Democratic >> So this is this is even a meta
level
like at a meta level Hutch is committing the same wrong again.
At a meta level, he can't integrate that Josiah can retain in
his mind the entire conversation history so far. And so he's
trying to relitigate this and explain something that is totally
irrelevant, right? You can say that oh, I wanted another example.
The problem came after he gave you the example. None of the things
you're talking about relate to why he's upset.
and should possibly ignore the Supreme Court. Was that the Was
that the only time it came up? I can't think of any other example
where I told Pisco like a like a specific example where the court
should be That wouldn't matter. >> Okay, then I have the
wrong Listen, I have the wrong impression then, bro. But here's
here's the frustration.
I I gave you all that information before you responded the way
you did. And this is actually part of the problem, right? Which
is going back to my initial question about where you said where
I'm too online.
And I've said this to you before and I Wait a minute. I've said
this to you before and I said this to you I've said this to you
in multiple conversations before, including the one earlier today,
where you and I can just exchange straw men about one another.
By the way, I hate to say it, okay?
I think I've seen this lopsided pixel guy in my Twitch chat.
He's definitely watched some of the things I've said about Hutch
and recognized this because I'm just telling you I'm just telling
you guys that's definitely happened here. I'm just I'm just saying.
I'm just I'm just saying. I'm just saying. Matt, thank you for
the five. Appreciate it, man. Thank you. Thank you. >> If
you want No, I'm No, I'm glad you clarified. Listen, I'm glad
you clarified. I appreciate that. I'm giving Hang on. I'm giving
you like inside into why I was thinking this The reason I said
anything online, I was responding to Peace Pisco said, "You are
start quote." And I I think I Hutch didn't lose That's like Sorry,
Josiah didn't lose his temper till after that. He might have
He was He sounded annoyed when he first joined, but he was calm,
right? He was calm. And then you doubled down on that comment
to his face after he gave you an example of why he believes these
things can be talked about or why he flirted with it. So, you
can't you can't throw it back to Pisco and talk about something
with Pisco or some reason for doing this because after he gave
you full information, you still condescended. You still called
him too online. I quote here He said Josiah is starting to talk
about like possibly ignoring the Supreme Court. So, But what
I'm working off of, That's what's That's what's in my head. And
so in that context, I hear that and I'm like, that's way too
online if we're just casually talking about ignoring the
So again, at a meta level, Hutch has been caught basically lying
to try to get out of Josiah being mad because Josiah could recall
the entire conversation so far. Hutch just did another like gaslight
attempt that is based on Josiah not being able to retain the
entire history of the conversation.
Like Like you're pretending Josiah doesn't know that after that
he discussed it with you. He gave you his opinion and then you
said, "Well, maybe I can respect that opinion because you give
me an example." And then he gave you an example, you went, "Yeah,
that's too online, bro." You You doubled down after hearing everything
he had to say, all of his context. You still said the same thing.
So you It goes out of Pisco's hand at that point and into yours.
If you're If you're talking about a potential hypothetical where
it's, you know, like the global meltdown of the entire like interconnected
economy, if it's like avoiding that, then it's the same like
trolley problem harm reduction principle. I would totally be
willing to entertain. But again, my impression of where you were
at and you being too
So if you just said all of that to me He did say all of that
to you.
And And again,
I I don't know. It's It's actually the The flight example is
just perfect,
Like Like Hutch, the requirement to gaslight Josiah here is the
capacity for flight that Hutch doesn't have. Hutch doesn't have
wings. He can't do it. That's the That would That is what is
required, okay? And Hutch doesn't have it. Wait, can you acknowledge
that, though? If I'm If I'm told >> No, I No, I can't.
No. No. No, respectfully, I can't. Not I understand you having
that impression. No. No. No, I can't. No. No. No, respectfully,
I can't. Not
I understand you having that impression
going in,
but then when you ask the question the first time and I answered
it, whatever misapprehension you were under or implication you
got from Pisco should have went out the window. >> No,
come on, bro. >> No, yes.
Like but the like I I
I'm glad I called this earlier than a lot of other people, okay?
I'm not to suck myself off too hard. But like it is a capacity
thing. He doesn't understand, he can't perceive what he's never
experienced. He doesn't understand that Josiah is like like Josiah
has
like proof of the [snorts] way things
and Hutch like basically lacks he it's almost like he's blind
and Josiah is he's he's blind and he's arguing that something's
a triangle that's a square. And Josiah can see the thing and
he's going, "You you literally can't see. I can see that you
can't see it." And Hutch Hutch is saying, "No, I see it. It's
a triangle." But it's like a square. Josiah does have the spark.
Yes, this is the same thing I'm talking about in a lot of these
cases, right? No, no, no, no, that's not No, no, no, that's not
it. That's not it, Rile.
Hutch didn't even listen.
Hutch didn't even listen. I understand that that could be a thing
here, right? I I think that that could be a small part of it,
but Hutch didn't even
He didn't have respect enough to listen because even if he didn't
understand that that's what was happening, he would have heard
respected legal this guy Josiah respects this guy who's like
somebody to take seriously who's not just operating online. There
are so many indicators you could have gone off of to know that
Josiah's opinion is grounded and you should respect it even if
you don't understand it.
Right? But it's like the ego on top of everything that made him
just dismiss.
Yes, because Pisco didn't give you specific examples. Now, if
you'll allow
to to talk about the context that Pisco and I have talked about
this in. So, one of the issues that I wrestle with all the time
in my version of the Supreme Court of my assessment of the Supreme
Court is the fact that we don't have three co-equal branches.
We have three coordinate branches. And the founders were very
very clear that the Supreme Court was intended to be the weakest
of the branches, weaker than the president, and Congress was
supposed to be stronger than both. It's supposed to be Congress,
then the president, then the Like at best or I guess rather I
could even integrate that because it's a part of what I was already
saying is that Hutchkin here talking about the debt ceiling,
talking about defaulting on the debt, but he doesn't he can't
there's no second-order thought process that kicks off to go,
"Well, if we defaulted on the debt, what happens?" So, once Josiah
says the consequences, once he does the second-order thinking
for Hutch, then Hutch is capable of understanding. Sure, I think
that's the same thing essentially, but I do think all of the
context indicators are there to say that this is a serious thing.
Why does this person take this seriously in a way that I don't?
I like again, not to suck myself off, but when I was watching
the Airdite thing with the with the What is it? Agrippa's
I don't know philosophy.
I assume Airdite reads a little philosophy, and I'm like, "I'm
very careful about saying like, 'Oh, I'm just going to condescend
and act like this person's retarded' without looking into some
of this stuff, without trying to think of other possibilities
because realistically, that's what intellectual humility intellectual
humility is. Right? You're trying to think of like, "Well, I
this is somebody who's capable of thinking." Like I I'm trying
to understand what they're thinking so that I'm not mischaracterizing
what they're trying to do here. Supreme Court. And one of the
things that I wrestle with all the time is in practice, it's
Okay. So, we we keep going. >> Supreme Court on top because
the Supreme Court can effectively issue commands
to the other two branches,
and the expectation since Marbury versus Madison and particularly
since the Civil War has been if the Supreme Court issues an order,
the other two branches are obligated to obey. So, the Supreme
Court can strike down federal statute
and can also strike down executive
Well, what options do the other two branches have? Well, Congress
really can't do anything, right? If if the if Congress passes
a law and it's signed into law by the president, so you have
two branches versus one. The Supreme Court reviews that law passed
by Congress, signed by the president, and says, "Oh, it's unconstitutional.
We're striking it down." The only way to get
Enduring politics. Uh-huh. >> And at that point, other
than This wasn't sensitive. It's it's
Like I I don't I don't want to overblow this cuz I know people
will think that I just dislike Hutch and that's why I'm overblowing
it. It's not sensitivity. I think I've done a good job for anybody,
even if you don't really follow so closely, I think I've done
a good job for almost anyone to see that Josiah's totally justified
in being upset. That so long as you can have the whole context
of conversation, the trying to convince me he shouldn't even
be mad at the end, I think Josiah's just trying to keep talking
so that he can let the anger simmer down because again, he he
Hutch did try to gaslight him again at the end of the conversation.
That this is why this happened. And Hutch Sorry. Hutch tried
to gaslight Josiah on why this this happened. And Josiah corrected
him again, little bit angry. Like even if whatever Pisco said,
once I explained, you should have not need Pisco's thing anymore.
That doesn't matter anymore, right?
Did somebody say, "Can we blame Oger boy?" Oh, can we just blame
Oger boy? Jesus Christ, man.
Anyway, Josiah explained it. Now he's just trying to go off on
a in a different direction so that he can get out of here without
freaking out on this guy again. Probably hoping that Probably
hoping that Hutch can't retain enough context. Once Josiah's
talked enough, Hutch's mind goes totally blank and Hutch will
just be like, "Oh, hey Josiah, where'd you come from?" Like once
if you if he could speak for 60 seconds uninterrupted in any
conversation with Hutch, he forgets where he is. That's that's
like the level of RAM he's got going on in his
If you can just talk uninterrupted for 60 seconds, he forgets
the room he's in. Getting the court to change its mind or packing
the court or something is to do a constitutional amendment. And
we've had 27 constitutional amendments in 250 years out of literally
more than 10,000 attempts. We have the hardest constitution to
amend in the world. And the president than 10,000
People think this is personal. I mean, it kind of is personal.
>> attempts we have the hardest constitution to amend in
the world. And the president by himself is effectively totally
powerless against the Supreme Court. The Supreme Oh, hold on.
I I don't mean to cut Josiah off. One thing NSAA is like really
good at is being a philosophically intellectual scholar. Well,
actually, it's probably my lack of respect for her intellectual
capabilities that leads me to be careful there cuz I don't want
to just I I
that I probably underestimate what she's capable of in some way,
even though that sounds difficult, okay? I don't want to look
like an idiot by saying something like by just painting her as
an idiot and then I look like Hutch, right? Where I don't understand,
I paint her as an idiot and then I look like Hutch.
I don't want that to happen. So, that's why I'm intellectually
curious or cautious. Especially in situations where I like already
have a developed opinion of of someone. Right? If it like if
I were in Hutch's scenario with somebody I know is intelligent,
I would be cautious to just dismiss them because probably they
have a good point to make, right?
And if I'm in the the erudite snarking scenario, I'm like, "Okay,
I don't really respect this person. It's probably going to make
me make snap judgments on them without really being rigorous
about it at all." It's like the opposite process at play both
times. Supreme Court can tell the president no. And then under
our current system, the president is oblig- I guess that's sort
of letting my biases like go hard, which I'm totally okay with.
>> -gated to obey. So, as I've talked with Pisco multiple
times, how is that if anything other than a total inversion of
what the founders intended? If I can tell you no and you're obligated
That's a That's a great example of like
Like Hutch almost certainly can't retain this and understand
>> version of what the founders intended. How is that not
an inversion of what the founders intended? If I can tell you
no and you're obligated to obey,
then we're not equals. I'm your boss. So, we've had that conversation,
but I have never that I can think of ever advocated other than
the the debt ceiling situation for
a president to just simply disregard the Supreme Court. But philosophically
and in terms of checks and balances and separation of powers,
yes, I think it's a really good question because the Supreme
Court is ultimately in our current system the most powerful branch.
>> But you know I'm a But So, hang on. I just want to Hold
on. I'm pulling up the transcript from the podcast last night.
I just want to
I just want to get exactly what was said, okay? Cuz if memory
serves correctly, where is it?
I do a control F search for Josiah and it's not popping popping
up. I don't know the exact timestamp.
Yeah, I I remember what he said. I understand. So, I
Like Hutch Hutch is still not listening. He's just thinking,
"How do I use Pisco to get out of trouble with Josiah?" That's
the only thing on Hutch's mind right now. How can I use this
Pisco transcript where Pisco's talking about this to get out
of trouble with Josiah?
But it is irrelevant.
Which only The only person who could think it's relevant is somebody
who is ground bound, okay? Somebody who lacks the capacity to
fly. I think I think Pisco was a bit overstating
Okay. my position. All >> But we have talked about the
notion of non-acquiescence.
And as far as the
But are we in a fascist state? Present
I don't know what you're asking. >> Again, the only one
I Um if you want to make a point, if you're like here to defend
Hutch, you can just hop in the Discord if that's what you're
trying to do. I can't tell. This might also just be a bot. I
actually don't know.
can think of ever publicly flirting with is the the debt ceiling
example. But Hutch, I love you. You're a friend, and that's part
of the reason why I was like, I'm not playing. You really pissed
me off. And the reason Um if you're if you're a viewer, you can
hop in the Discord if you want to have a conversation about what
you think is happening here with Hutch. Totally fine with that.
I I say that cuz I don't recognize your name, and you haven't
typed. I'm not saying that literally like sometimes there are
bots that seem to like piece or cobble together context from
the chat and say messages that seem somewhat coherent.
But if you want to hop in the Discord, we can talk about it.
discord.gg/jcsok.
You can hop in, and we can discuss it if you want to discuss
it. >> reason you really pissed me off is I understand
if you had a certain conception of me based on what Pisco said,
but as soon as you asked the
and I'm like, well, I can't I can't think of a single example.
And then and then I'm like, okay, well, here's this one specific
modern example. And for you to react the way that you did was
incredibly disrespectful and condescending, especially for a
guy who doesn't like you you say all the time you've said it
in conversations with me about how you feel that, you know, you're
being straw manned or misrepresented. You ask people to, you
know, give the the steel man of your impression. I feel you do
that to me. And so that's why I came in here actually just asked
the question like
>> right now. Let me just say real quick. I Okay, go ahead.
I had a talk He's about to He just didn't listen again. He just
didn't listen again. I do wonder how this ends because he just
didn't listen again. And I do think at like this point
I I do think at this point
he's not listening so he has no way to fix it he's not listening
he's just trying to think of how to get out of
but listen you're steamrolling me no he's explaining to you and
you're not
he's explaining to you it would be terrible it would be absolutely
terrible if Hutch did something again that indicated that after
what you said you said that he's not listening not paying attention
not concerned with what Josiah has to say that probably be the
worst case scenario for Hutch >> totally different impression
and it was not my intention to straw man you and it does look
like I was mischaracterizing
your perspective and I wasn't doing that intentionally I was
working off of in my head again I'm being told that the impression
is that you're starting to
just so so now twice I believe twice Josiah has explained I think
twice that what your previous conception was doesn't matter your
previous perception before doesn't matter because I explained
my entire opinion to you and you're not listening to it you dismissed
it after I went to painstaking
to explain it to you
talk about non-acquiescence
in a more general sense okay so that's where my head is at and
when when you gave me your one specific answer that doesn't like
nullify what I heard like you that wasn't you saying this is
the only time I would ever entertain that I'm still in my head
going off of what Pisco told me which is that he's starting to
talk about doing that okay so if if
for for misrepresenting anything you said I apologize I really
do I appreciate that I don't think I don't think I don't think
I don't think I don't think I don't think I don't think I don't
think I don't think I don't think I don't think I don't think
think I don't it It a throw it was a throwaway line that was
that's all it was. It wasn't even Wasn't a throw away line. It
wasn't a throw away line. Hutch was clearly annoyed, sorry, Josiah
was clearly annoyed about you saying it. He came in, he gave
it, he laid out his whole thing and you doubled down on the same
thing that was already annoying
Right? You doubled down on that. You said that's just really
online, bro. And the worst part is you said it without thinking
about his example or or listening to it at all. That's what you
>> Even, you know, I have like strong disagreements with
with like Steven right now. And I I said By by the way, it's
actually still a lie to even say he strawmanned him. He didn't
misunderstand. He didn't like mischaracterize what Josiah was
thinking. He just didn't listen. He didn't He didn't even respond.
He didn't like say, "Well, you just want to overthrow the government."
He was like, "Oh, I just think it's really crazy to ever ponder
this." Which is not the conversation they were having, which
is why Josiah responded with, "Hey, [__] It's about
when you would do it, not if it's possible or okay to do it.
Obviously, there are situations where it's okay to do it." >> Jesus.
Said the same thing about him, but it's [clears throat] not It
is kind of like half banter, okay? But I was not working off
of the It sounds like the reality of the situation. If you're
saying Wasn't half banter. >> that the whole non-acquiescence
thing came up in the context of this particular thing and the
greater harm in this case could be like a global catastrophic
meltdown, then sure, I would be entertained that and I would
say that you're not too online, okay?
That's what he said to you. And your response was, "You're too
>> I had I did not have the I did not have the I did not
He's not going to be able I don't know if Josiah is going to
be able to let it go. Josiah is polite in like the southern way.
Like he is polite until you've given him a reason not to be polite.
I've never seen him like this. Not I don't think I've ever seen
Josiah like this, ever, okay? But he is polite until you give
him a reason not to be. He's got like the southern Is it hot
southern hospitality kind of deal? Right? He's polite until you
give him a reason not to. And Hutch just did a thing again where
he's like trying to get out of this without really acknowledging
what happened here.
And I you would expect this from your friend to say I wasn't
listening to you. I dismissed you in a totally condescending
way despite the fact that you had the idea. You had you had these
thoughts. I didn't I didn't listen. I dismissed you. Instead
he's saying, "Well, I thought something from before and like
I don't know, man. I just didn't I didn't if you explained it
to me that like the debt ceiling would cause huge chaos. It's
like no, I I think probably there is an element here of Josiah
probably assumed you knew that
that welching on the debt on dismiss What is it? Uh like Uh there's
a word for whatever you do. Welching on the I'm going to call
welching on the debt. Like that causes things to explode. He
probably assumed you knew that. have the correct impression of
your attitude with respect to non-acquiescence. And I agree with
you on like 99% of your prescriptions when it comes to the Right.
And so again, the the only other time this has come up is just
broad structural philosophical notions like is are the other
two branches obligated to obey the Supreme Court? And if so,
doesn't that necessitate that the Supreme Court be the most powerful
branch if they can tell the other two branches what to do, but
neither of the other two branches can tell it what to As in if
the founders are writing that the Supreme Court is intended to
be the weakest branch, but the powers
the explicitly stated powers such as they are allow the Supreme
Court to essentially rule over the other two
Right? The Supreme Court has the ability to invalidate both the
president and Congress, but they've been described as the weakest
branch. That implies there's some implicit power that allows
the other two branches to hold power over the Supreme Court.
Non-acquiescence is one of the proposed ways I I presume that
this could be like explained.
seems to be a vertical relationship and not I agree. I agree
with the binding code of ethics. I I agree with the binding code
of ethics. I agree with term limits. I I would be open to packing
the courts. Like you know this about me, okay? By the way, right
there, I would be open to packing the courts. How is that not
in the same way violating a norm that defeats like the like the
principal
liberal values of of America. You are essentially using the presidency
to pack the court, right?
That to me that's they're almost almost horizontal. They're almost
like the same.
Now, obviously non-acquiescence is like immediate instant. You
could do it whenever you want, technically.
And packing the court would have some more process to it, but
I do think that like they're generally almost the same. I I know,
but I know and that's not I'm but I'm not talking about that.
I'm I'm trying to give you the context of when non-acquiescence
has come up in conversations with Peace Corps. The only specific
example are the Civil War example with President Lincoln and
Chief Justice Taney. And the debt ceiling crisis under Biden,
okay?
uh it's not as bad for the exact same reason even less, but it's
it it is like the same idea, right? I don't like that the Supreme
Court is ruling against me as the president. I'm going to pack
the court. That's the idea, right? That aside, what as far as
the two online part cuz I remember you saying this. It's wasn't
even just about the Supreme Court, but again about the strength
of Trump. So, that's actually it wasn't even about the court
why I came in here. I came to ask you why you think I'm too online
when it comes to Trump. And I'm curious if you could clarify
a bit more. I'm trying to figure out where we're missing each
other. You touched on it a bit earlier, but I had to go and record
some video. So, now that I have time, can you talk about it a
bit more? Yeah, I So, first of all, I just want to reiterate
again that I I apologize for disrespecting you in that way. We're
going to preface this by No, they're both abusing norms even
Uh basically
have they been abused have they been used more than one another?
Like I think probably the amount of times you've seen genuine
non-acquiescence is probably about the same amount you've seen
the court packed quote unquote in some way,
Characterize it, okay? I I genuinely apologize for that. So,
I I will I will for sure remember Reps have stolen two seats,
so packing makes sense. Okay, well, Donald Trump has talked about
non-acquiescence. Donald Trump has attempted non-acquiescence.
Non-acquiescence seems to be a strategy they're employing.
So, non-acquiescence is justified? Remember this conversation
and make more of an effort to be respectful of um you overall
in my rhetoric, okay? But a lot of it A lot of it is kind of
like half-friendly banter, but touching on some very real frustrations.
But if I ever cross any kind of line like that, I do apologize.
I I don't I he he doesn't understand. He actually still Honestly,
somebody should take if Rile puts this up on YouTube, somebody
should take that video and send it to Hutch so he can understand
because he actually still doesn't understand why his friend is
mad. He's still